and replacement for uh representative
southworth would be amanda baldwin
and replacement for representative
bernstein
is keith ammon
that's fine right there
and replacement for mary griffin
is
adrian
annika
and replacement for amanda gorg is wendy
chase
okay
now
representative bernstein is a clerk he's
out today
representative lang is going to take
over his court
he asked to
delay this for about five minutes
because he has to
present a bill and finance and he'll be
back by five after ten so we're going to
do that
otherwise we're in trouble if we don't
that's a good
that's a good question but the first
thing we're going to deal with is house
yes yeah can i answer that question so
so yeah he i i saw our representative
lying this morning he had a final final
version that he was trying to push
through
so that's why we don't have it yet
right and he'll he should be here
to
dude i think it's coming in the door no
no
no is that it
um
okay right
okay i'm going to open the
temporary clerk is
with us and we'll give them time but we
can get started
and we have an amendment that was put
together jointly by
representative aaron and representative
schomberg
and
whether
representative aaron or schomburg
okay represent aaron you want to explain
thank you mr chair sorry i got to get
myself together here
yes so
representative schomburg brought an
amendment last time we met and so did i
and we just took those two amendments
and put them together
to have a complete amendment to the
uh
bill hb 1584
which would provide a um
a capital improvement program for this
the state fairs or agricultural affairs
in new hampshire
and
basically you know we are making a
statement that it's in the public
interest to
advance encourage and protect
agricultural affairs including the
exhibition of livestock and agricultural
produce of all kinds
and with these fair exhibitions as they
need funds to help them
maintain and upkeep their
infrastructure
the barns the buildings
that need maintenance
we feel that it's important to have the
state
establish a fund that the commissioner
of agriculture would
sort of have
control over that
to to distribute these funds
to the
fairs and
in the places that are in need of
infrastructure repairs
so um
we have the definitions in this
amendment to uh to define what we're
talking about when we're talking about
the commissioner the department the fair
the fund itself meaning the capital
improvement program fund for the fairs
established in
this rsa
the capital improvement program grant
fund
would have each fiscal year
the state treasurer would transfer into
this capital improvement grant fund
the sum of 250 000 and my amendment
which was incorporated into this
would put a cap on that fund of a
million dollars
so that you know at least we have
a fund that's not going to accrue and
accrue and accrue funds
this way we have a mechanism to say well
if there's a million dollars in this
fund then the state doesn't have to kick
in any more money into it
other parts of this here in page two
uh line three
and
all the way to uh line 24
gives the conditions by which
grants would be eligible to
the
agricultural affair associations
and so those are enumerated in this
section
to
going on to the next page as well
the capital improvement grant
disbursements
and how
that whole mechanism would work
the commissioner would may allocate 95
of the capital improvement program grant
funds
including fund interest to eligible
applicant fares
and distribute those funds according to
merit as measured by a merit rating set
we have another the next section which
is on page three
uh also defining
uh how the department would develop and
manage appropriate contracts with the
selected applicants
provisions in the contracts
and
you know just basically how this program
would work
there's also a reporting mechanism that
was added in
on page 3 lines 24-30
which says that
annually the commissioner would compile
a report
detailing the number of disbursements
from this fund the amount of each
disbursement
the entities that received the
disbursement and the purposes of the
disbursement and so on
and that report would be distributed to
the house of representatives as
the speaker of the house the president
of the senate
chairpersons of house ways and means and
house and senate
finance committees
and
house and senate committees with
jurisdiction over environmental and
agricultural issues by november 1st of
each year so there's a reporting
mechanism that was added into this bill
too
there's also an auditing
section
and
and how those audits should take place
um also
on page four we talk about um you know
what happens if there's a failure to
keep any kind of records or books on
this
and um and that's pretty much what this
um
what this amendment does is is really
kind of uh
get into the weeds and clarify
how this program will work and how the
funds should be set up and how the funds
should be dispersed from this fund so
thank you thank you representation uh we
have the commissioner here commissioner
sean jasper of
the commissioner of agriculture
have you seen this
amendment and do you agree
yes yes i have i had um proposed a a
version of this late last last week
um and
it's been much improved over what i uh
what i had proposed and i am in support
of it part of
what i did and the reason you'll see it
moves to 425 because there was already a
section that authorized
money's going to the fair it just has
not had money appropriated to it but it
went in a different way so this was the
audit function
is what is in current law
so that's already there and so this just
melds the proposed bill
together with current law and make some
great improvements to it in my my
opinion and
i i appreciate the work that went into
this
does anybody have any questions
i hope there's a good answer to this
because i don't want to
have to redo it
but on page 3 line 31
the oh it it also is in current law but
it referred to on the old agricultural
fare support
program which hasn't been respected for
decades apparently
on
what
what does it mean now repairs
in case of partial or total destruction
of the building by fire or otherwise the
commissioner may make needed repairs or
replacement with the approval of
governor and council
and use proceeds of any insurance i
think it originally was talking about
the
new hampshire building at the newink new
england i forget what you call it
states fair
i don't believe so
the
19 was simply about the fairs
law dealing with
the big e is in a separate section of
law
so i think this
really was about the case if buildings
were destroyed on fairgrounds
that rather than going through the
entire process we could
react more quickly than than normal to
allow those buildings to be back up and
running again
because obviously it's one thing to to
plan for an upgrade or a facility or a
that wouldn't impact the ongoing
operation but if the building is
destroyed by
by fire such as what we saw
at
granite state which is the old rochester
that would impact that year's
fare so this section would allow that to
take place much more quickly i would
simply need to go to g and c to make
that happen so thank you i think i think
this makes sense
saying no further questions
then i
uh
anybody else have
anything to say
i don't see anything so what i'm going
to do is
thank you mr chairman i'm not sure if
this question is really aimed at
commissioner jasper
or the co-sponsors but
on the bottom of page one
in lines 31 and 32
a new sentence has been added to
create the
upper limit of a million dollars of the
accumulated capital
but if i'm reading it correctly
this says that in any year in in which
the balance is more than a million
dollars no transfer will be made
but in any year in which the
balance is under a million
a transfer would be made so my question
is there happens to be 999
a thousand dollars in the account does
that mean 250 goes in and it becomes a
million 249
represent aaron do you
i would imagine that would be true
um
but
i i think that the
particularly using the words is at least
implies that that is the answer but i'm
not sure whether it was the intended
answer i thought perhaps the intention
was to set a ceiling of a million
and to make a transfer
in the amount that would close the gap
but not exceed a million
any responses
mr chair
representative chamber may i ask the
commissioner presently how much money is
that grant or that fund right now for
this well the fund that
previously in theory exists is the
premium fund and there is no money in
that that account that has been a
dormant account
since sometime in the 80s
follow-up
do you see this
amount of money ever reaching a million
dollars just theoretically
the only time i would see that is if
there was an extreme need on on one fare
and everything else was doing well so if
there was a we knew that there was a
building or an infrastructure need that
was going to exceed a million dollars
and couldn't be done in phases then i
could see that as a possibility i do not
see that as a likelihood
but i think the answer the question is
if there was 990 000 or you know
999 000 in there you put
you know went out up to
1.2 49 million
um that wouldn't
be a bad thing but if it stayed at that
level there'd be no distribution in the
next year so
um i would hope that that would not be
something
there could be planning ongoing
any further questions or comments
if not i'm coming out of the work
session
yeah i do
okay representative romney
so
in hearings i was saying that not nephew
uh
mr commissioner no this is just a
general comment for the group
so
i was the one saying that this bill was
really a finance bill but came to us
but we got word from the chair of
finance that this will be funded if we
pass it the 250 000 at least for next
year
so i just thought you would want to know
that thank you
[Music]
just continuing on that same subject i
guess uh that
makes clear what i
is my understanding that there will need
to be an appropriation
each year
for each each budget year
for this
for it to happen don't believe that just
having these words in this bill
mean that 250 000 is going to transfer
automatically right
right all i all we know is that in the
second year of this
this two-year budget that the second
year of the budget there will there will
be they will fund that 250 000
but
and going forward we have no idea it's
every legislature will come up with
representative
just to to get that a little bit closer
uh
if
on the way that it would stop coming
is
either
that they change this law or
that the finance committee puts into the
budget as they frequently do we're not
doing this law this year
in other words we're suspending this
section
and they could always do that yeah
any further uh representative spellsbury
yes thank you mr chairman i mean others
more experienced in this sort of law
will give me a quick answer on this in
in lines 28 and 29
the fun shall be non-lapsing and
continually appropriated does that
phrase refer only to those funds that
have been carried over from prior years
representative tucker well i'd just like
to thank the people who spent so much
time on what seems to be
you know a small amount of money
relative to what we often deal with but
these pairs are very important
in this state and i'm
really delighted to be able to
get it all worked out and then i can
vote yes
it hasn't yet we need to vote on it i
know
any further questions or comments
if not we're going to go into executive
session on house bill
1584-fn
and
our clerk
representative malloy are you ready to
call the vote
and the motion is oh we need emotions
right
representative aaron you want to make a
motion
yes mr clerk i would like to uh move
that
uh
ought to pass um with an amendment
do we do the amendment first or
actually we need to pass the amendment
okay so i i
i move that we uh ought to pass
amendment 1156h
and i'll second that mr seconded by
now
we need
all those in favor of passing this
amendment
just raise your hand
oppose
unanimous
so now representative aaron
thank you mr chair
i move we pass
hb 1584 as amended
uh with an otpa
so
with amendment
1156h
any questions or comments
on the motion about to pass as amended
of the amendment
saying none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the vote
and
and what you're doing is it's ought to
pass with amendment
yes
representative
ankerberg
yes
representative
senator aaron yes
representative jennings
yes
representative nunez yes
representative
yes
representative spillsberry yes
representative tudor yes
representative all me
yes
representative ames yes
representative bolden
yes
representative malloy acting clerk votes
representative chamber
yes
tucker yes
representative
yes
represent lockman is not here
representative chase
yes
i'm sorry uh chair uh representative
major
yes
the vote been 22-0 the motion about to
pass as a
with amendment
passes
without
objection you go on consent
you see no objection so it will be on
consent
now we're out of executive session we're
we're going to work session on house
bill 1598-fn
enact legalizing the possession and use
now i want to remind the committee
that the policy of the use of cannabis
has been set
by the full house by a vote of two to
one
we're here to look at the only the
economic
part of the bill
what we will do to raise revenues
by representative lang which is
yes
representative
given a lot of the discussion is going
to be based on an agreement that we
should all have as to what we think the
net revenue is going to be to the state
so can we have an informal conversation
about that and maybe an offline vote
because that would not be part of the
that would not be part of the amendment
it's more
what we think as a committee the
revenues will be
once it's up and running for a while not
not the first year we know it's gonna
it's gonna
you know we we came up with a number of
about
50 million uh but when we take out the
uh i think we talked about last time if
we take out the edibles
that would go down by 40 so whatever
so i i just want to make sure that
because someone's going to ask us that
what what does the
committee officially believe the
revenues are going to be
i can see that happening on the floor or
wherever
we should at least have our official
agreement on that if we cut
it may not be unanimous agreement but we
should have a a vote on that
separate whether it's a straw poll or
however the chair wants to handle that
um
all me
i believe that the
the
report
blurb
is supposed to contain a revenue
estimate
particularly if the original revenue
estimate was very vague because this one
was
let me ask representation you were
yes mr chair i apologize i am working on
a chart in excel to show the revenue
estimates i think we ran through it last
time and i gave some numbers based on
both the estimate and the cost on the
fact that we're doing
for lack of a better word a stagger
staged
rollout right that we're not going to do
all 10 stores on day one i can run
through the numbers again
if anybody wants and then i'll email
them out to everybody i honestly we're
expecting one more amendment to replace
the amendment that's on our table
because i got some conversations over
the weekend and i got an email from mr
simon up this morning that had some
language changes i thought were
appropriate we can go over those i've
already sent them the ols
but they're all still based off the
amendment that we have in front of us
which is 11.52
but if you want to run through the
revenue estimates for you so we have a
general idea what we're talking about
why don't you just run through them
great
so i based all of our revenue estimates
off the uh the sheet given to us by the
new hampshire liquor commission
on the new hampshire commission they
estimated our gross revenues around 250
million dollars however and our our net
revenues or i should say our our gross
net gross gross
gross net at um 50 million dollars to
the state so we'll sell 200 million 250
million dollars worth of product out of
that 250 million dollars we expect will
generate about 50 million dollars in
profit for the state
from that profit we have we we have to
realize that this does not include
edibles right that their original
estimates were based on
selling all the products
we on a conservative basis chose 40
percent meaning that we actually i think
it's going to be less than that but 40
percent was the amount of revenue that
was generated towards edibles so from
that
50 million dollars you have to subtract
20 20 million dollars
is the lost revenue because we're not
going to be selling edibles at on a
recreational side so our new uh adjusted
is is the gross that'll be coming into
the state from that and then we can so
that's the number that we'll be
receiving and then from there there's
some expenditures that come out of that
but 30 million is a rough estimate
once all the stores are up and up and
running based on the
testimony
and the stores you're talking about is
that 10 stores
right so the the basis was the revenues
uh estimates were all based off 10
stores um and the original 14 million
dollar ask we've decided in in
consultation with the laker commission
that we're not doing all 10 stores year
one the reality is they'll build three
to four stores which only requires a 4.6
million dollar ask of the state
so it'll be two to three years before
we're at a full revenue projection so in
the first year we can assume it's going
to be one-third of that 30 million
dollars so our profit's going to be
about 10 million dollars in the first
year 30 million 20 million dollars in
the second year and then in the third
year we'll be at 30 million dollars so
it's approximately 10 million dollars if
they keep adding three to four stores
each year it'll go up by
10 million each year until we get where
we're at
and there's nothing limiting us to 10
stores that's correct so again in the
amendment we talked about this briefly
in the um hearing there's no limitations
in the um in the bill for the number of
stores so to fix the fact that if we
need more than 10 stores um we i treated
this just like we do liquor stores in in
liquor all the revenue that comes in if
the if the state wants to open up
another store it has to come out of
their gross net profits their operating
expense so they add the cost of a new
store into their operating expense and
then subtract it from the revenue that
comes from that that came into the state
so we're doing the same exact model with
the cannabis stores so as the state
makes money they can hold back some of
the profits from disbursement so they
can open the next store
so it's a as they make revenue they can
open up more stores with the 10 million
dollars they'll be able to it's
estimated that they'll make enough money
to open three stores in the second year
it does mean that we don't get as much
disbursement in that first year to the
other agencies because we're using it to
open up the next set of stores so it'll
take a while before we get to full full
boat so to speak and all the agencies
will start getting their money at a
higher level
would you say that these are
moderate conservative
estimates i believe they're extremely
conservative estimates i think that
they'll actually make more revenue than
we're projecting but i also don't want
to over project and then come up short
thank you representative
any questions representative lang
so i've been thinking about our
conversation last
friday and uh on this edibles question
and uh
with it out of the uh
picture for the liquor commission
what uh
we did on friday and what representative
lang and his faith
truly accurately uh reported is uh to
look at sort of the proportion
that edibles have uh been of
the total sales in other states
and uh
that's where the 40 percent on the
conservative side
comes from
but
if new hampshire has stores in which
edibles are not sold
won't it be the case that customers
near the borders on either side of the
border
who have stores nearby in our
neighboring states
where edibles are sold
that they will that customers will
still go to those stores if edibles are
important
to their consumption pattern
um
rather than across the border the liquid
commissions
oh i'm sorry
the liquor commission will not be in the
position that it is with liquor
similar products on either side of the
border being able to
sell
premier products
that are in direct competition with
products of the same
premier quality
at a lower price it will simply not have
the product and if it doesn't have the
product people will not come to the
store
and won't buy the products that the
liquor commission does have even though
they might be at a lower price
because
they'll get
what they want which may include both
kinds of products
uh locally um so my sense my expectation
would be that the loss would be greater
than the proportion
uh that the sales in other states show
because of this phenomenon you know you
go to the store that has
all the things you want not to this
store and then that store unless there's
an extraordinary difference in price for
a part of the product so my expectation
would be we're going to lose more
representative
thank you i'll just remind the committee
i ran through these numbers with the
commissioner when they were here and
their anticipation is that these numbers
are accurate so that was there when they
were here and we i ran through both the
revenue side as well as the costing side
to see what was going to cost us to make
sure we had enough to roll back into the
program to open the next door so we
didn't have to do another appropriation
and the commissioners said that our
numbers were accurate and that they felt
that that was what they would project as
well on and i by no stretch know the
marijuana market by um and any any uh
provision but again i'm going to rely on
them they've done the they gave us the
first initial and i will also say
representative ames if you
and again the bill that's coming out
based on the conversation and based on
what i i know what's going on is as i as
i the amendment that we're waiting on
based on our conversation around edibles
is basically the the amendment i ask for
would define edibles is basically food
or drink
right so gummies cookies brownies
you can't get a red bill with cannabis
infused right so that would be that
those were going to be the prohibited
prohibitions on the liquor store
well that's welcome news i think we
needed that clarification well that's
that's what i put in was i put in that
it would it would it would be food or
drink cannabis infused food or drink
products
i'm sorry which also means that
and originally when we talked about
edibles we had we also included
cartridges to get to that 40 percent
because the the real number even if you
look at massachusetts numbers
are
uh the edibles as they define them which
includes basically the food and drink
products were only about 15 percent of
their mark of their product because the
the the cartridges and and the um
concentrates and the tinctures and the
uh the ointments or topicals um
would all now become
legally
able to sell in the state stores
and if i may uh
mr chair represent
i'd just like to respond to
representative lang's response to what i
said
i have great respect for the liquor
commissioner
but he is the liquor commissioner
and he's as new to cannabis as we are
well i should say as i am i know there
are others
in the room that are much more uh savvy
on this than i am
um
but i think uh common sense applies here
and uh if the liquor stores are narrowed
to selling
products that do not include edibles i
think the
the uh
impact on
sales and on
uh
sort of the uh the movement of customers
to the our stores rather than the
neighboring states stores will be
um
will be the impact will be greater and
the movement will be less to our stores
so
i would uh
say that although 40 seems conservative
at the beginning and may indeed have
included some items that were sold in
those other stores that will no longer
be edibles
under the new language
i uh
i still think that
that this model
with the liquor commission
is
likely to produce
more like half of what
uh it would produce but for this uh
exclusion of a much favored product from
everything we've heard
uh from the uh manual of items that the
representative romney
followed by representative tucker
okay thank you mr chair so
let's make sure we understand what the
liquor commission presented us
their analysis was based on a per capita
uh amount of revenue that it looks like
are brought in
so to me and you got to remember there's
only about 12 to 50 percent of the
population will partake in this
it's not it's not 50 percent it may be
growing a little bit but
it isn't like the market's going to
expand that much that we
when we legalize
so
uh no matter how much marketing they do
no 15.
thank you right
so
but but this is bait per capita so to me
when they said 50 million
that's the maximum that we're gonna get
once once the market once he's he'll
know when to stop opening stores
he'll he'll wisely open stores
and to a point where
you know
we're going to water it down the the
number of customers are going to come to
store there's only so many stores that
we can open on this
and uh and that's so you understand
that's the ba that's the maximum
the way this analysis was done which is
very similar to when i chaired the
marijuana commission and i want to bore
you with that but
we came up with an estimate of 50
million as well
uh again with with edibles
so i that's why i feel comfortable with
the 50 million
uh
i understand representative ames
i kind of agree with you a bit on that
that we may lose some customers if we
don't have edibles but i think we just
got to let this play out at this point
uh if we if we pass this and we'll see
but again
they based it on 35 and 54 cents the
average per capita
revenue and
and that's what they used and that was
for
not pers it's going to be a lot less if
we only have five stores open
it's it'll grow as we open more stores
but again it's going to reach a point
where the market's not going to grow
beyond a certain point
okay and and
and in my analysis in the liquor when we
did the marijuana commission
we included our state sales in that in
that analysis because we knew we would
get some out of state that would not be
in the per capita thing that we have and
we have a lot of tourists right
and i think representative abbott's kind
of
i think you've thought that through as
well and some of the comments you've
made over over time that we will attract
some out-of-state business as well
hopefully they're consuming in the state
because it would be illegal for them to
bring it back but that's not our
but
so that that's my comment on it
thank you okay um
before i go to representative tucker
the amendment made some definitions of
what's sellable
and
i just asked representative lang
what's not sellable by our stores are
the edibles and adjustables
but what is sellable
is the pre-rolls the accessories
topicals
the flour
cartridges and
concentrate according to the list i have
here essentially 18
of
the items
are not soluble
and
yeah and so that's defined in this
amendment is that correct
mr chair i apologize it's not defined in
this amendment it's because it came from
representative ames over the weekend and
i gave it to ols this morning so the
basically what i told ols is we want to
make sure the lane the only thing that's
prohibited from sale in the state
cannabis stores
would be
edibles as defined by food or drink so
again cookies
gummies brownies
your red bull with cannabis in it so
those kind of things would be prohibited
for sale but all other items would be
available so if you look at
uh the the sheet that representative
abrami had given out um again that
represents about 18 of the revenue so
again when i i was conservative when i
said i took out 40 of the revenue saying
that's what edibles was going to be i
think it's more likely 20. we'll have 10
million more dollars in there but
again i don't want to overestimate and
then come back short so i'd rather stick
to the 40
that we talked about
robson tucker yes i had a question and i
hope that if there's someone in the
audience who could answer it uh if uh
representative lang can't
we could call on them um
but do most people i mean i know nothing
about the topic uh really but do most
people most consumers
use both
edibles
and other cannabis products that that
really
to answer representative ames's question
or comments we need to understand do
most people
by sort of both sides of
the aisle in the store or
do most people buy one or the other and
knowing that really will answer the
question
as to whether or not
our sales along the massachusetts and
other borders will be affected by
the
prohibition of
food and drink edibles
do you know the answer are there other
people in the audience who might know
the answer i would have absolutely zero
idea but probably one of the atc people
in here could probably or that or the
gentleman from dhhs can answer
somebody who could provide some
so representative i think your question
is would people buy both flour and buy
gummies at the same time right yeah do
most people are they users of both
products
types of products
representative said i think just my
thought on this is is this is really
subjective it's dependent upon what the
customer wants if we were to take this
argument and apply it to what we have
for a model in the liquor store i would
contend that beer
and wine sales far exceed
hard liquor sales but that argument
could be made
on the model that we have for liquor
stores right now we can't come to a
in this we can all assume what we'd lose
as far as edibles
but i don't think we're going to come to
a rock solid number because the argument
can be made
you know against the
the liquor model that we have right now
i think we're going to have customers
that come to new hampshire to buy
whatever it is that they want and if
they look for another product they'll go
to another place if if they so desire so
i think a lot of this discussion is is
something we're not going to have a
representative abbas
thank you mr chairman
one part of the possession limits that's
not being taken to consideration
when it comes to the flower
the possession limit would be four
ounces which is significantly higher
than any of the
proposed legislation we've had in the
past i know hb 237 the possession limit
would have been one ounce so to the
extent that a consumer from out of state
did come to new hampshire to make a
purchase
the they would be able to purchase a
larger amount than they would under
other policies now will that offset the
loss of revenue from not allowing
certain edible products i can't answer
that exactly but there will be some
increased
uh revenue share to out-of-state
consumers because for that reason and
the reason why we made the possession
limit that high was exactly
for that reason was to
potentially capture out-of-state
consumers
representation
thank you mr chairman um i have a
question yes i have a question about um
representative lang's
numbers i don't know if i understood it
correctly i thought he said that once 10
stores are up and running the net will
be 30 million
okay
and then i think i also heard you say
for every store that's added after that
there's a 10 million dollar
increase in net so i'm not sure how did
no i apologize so again it goes it goes
as stores exceed that we get
if we use the same math we just used to
get where we were it's basically for
every three stores we're adding 10
million dollars worth of revenue right
so it as they grow that's kind of the
model that'll look like so it's about
three million per se per store roughly
yeah okay thank you
again that that's extremely conservative
representative
thank you mr chairman
uh
i think i agree with representative lang
now that he's explained i had not
realized that so much of what we used to
call edibles is vaping
uh
but
i wanted
uh with your permission to add uh
another question which uh would come up
later but which i might forget at that
point because i'm not sure where it is
in the bill
uh
do does this also exclude the
uh atc
edibles
from these stores so that the
the centers would stay
alive
so the current bill the current
amendment in front of you leaves
the medical
medical edibles in in the state cannabis
stores
um
and we can have a discussion around that
again i can prepare a bill that an
amendment that includes them in and
includes them out but the current one
includes them in and again
in this bill one of the things we added
is the ability for atc's to act as a
parrot with
to obtain a parallel license
to act as marijuana cultivators
manufacturers
and trans transport people for the state
program which gives them an entirely new
revenue stream for their for their uh
organizations so and again the reason in
doing that was a gives us access to
immediately to people growing marijuana
we're not we're not trying to ramp it up
so much and the new stores that are
opening have a source to be able to go
to
but the other reason is that we
recognize that we may be doing a little
harm in this bill um to those programs
and so to give them and this is the
trade-off to give them additional
revenue streams um you know we don't
know where this is going to go
ultimately
but as it's here i want to make sure
i recognize we are potentially doing
harm by allowing the medical marijuana
in the state store and i gave to
mitigate that harm i allowed them to
apply for a parallel license to the
state um to be able to make revenue up
so to speak
and
it's just a follow-up
on do we have any indication from that
group that they would be able to take
i there's nobody who's directly said
i'll apply for one of those licenses if
that's what you're asking for so if
you're looking for a definitive answer
the answer is no
if you're looking for a subjective
answer i'd argue that they're already in
the market and it gives them a way to
increase their market cap in their
market space and they jump on it right
away
are you all set representative
uh yeah i just
i would like
us to talk to them but thank you
representative ames
yeah i just wanted to say that based on
what's been said um
i'm fine with the 30 million dollar
figure that representative lang has come
up with i actually agree with
representative doucet that
at some point we just have to
acknowledge our limits and
in
estimating impact of things like those
that i
was expressing concern about the absence
of a sought-after product and how that
will affect particularly in interstate
movement
but uh 30 million dollars i think takes
into account
a number of
uncertainties and uh that's fine with me
if we need to
go forward and
try to get marching through the bill so
that we can
go to issues like that
representative ami just raised in a in
oh
represent gamalo i couldn't see you over
there i know i'm hiding again
um i just needed a clarification from
susan about what she just said about
vaping at the beginning of her question
and edibles
um
vapings cartridges are going to be sold
because that's correct
yes again the limit i i think um
originally we kind of when you say
ingesting right so you ingest is vaping
ingesting you know because then right so
came a question of what's ingestible so
to speak and so the amendment that i
requested from ols this morning was to
make sure we're clear that the idea of
edibles is the food and drink category
okay so so card cartridges would be
allowed
yes and also concentrates
topicals and uh
and pre-rolls
may i have one more question please
go ahead
um
i can't find what's in i can't find
what's included in the 250 million
it would be the sales of everything
including is that an estimate if we did
sell edibles
so i think the liquor commission when
they answered said that was their
assumption everything was legal
um and then so that's why we have to
start backing things out was because we
know we're not going to be selling the
uh edibles and so we have to back out
they theirs their original bill and
financial note was based on everything
being legal
my question is should they not be backed
out at the top out of the 250 million
and not on revenue because they're never
mathematically sure it comes back to the
same thing i could take twenty percent
out and actually
so i can do the math i can do the math
the other way i i just started with the
gross number they had and then backed
out of that
but i can do it the other way when i
send this sheet out
yeah i think it does make a difference
um
maybe
okay thank you
um
representative spellsbury thank you mr
chairman
i i understand there's another amendment
coming and i'm not sure what it's going
to modify but
would i be generally correct to assume
that what can be sold
is essentially
the aggregation of the definition of
cannabis
on page these are all on page two
the definition of cannabis
products
and the definition of cannabis
accessories and if that's not exactly
true what else there is there in the
bill that would either add to or
subtract
so
the cannabis products again
representative abbas did a good job in
making this a forward-looking bill um in
that if you look at catabol cannabis
products in the definition it includes
edibles
in the definition of what a cannabis
product is however later on in the bill
we have what we have a section where we
strike out the edibles right so you can
say all cannabis products except for and
that's what they're going to fix in the
bill that we just had
um is the or the amendment i'm
requesting is taking out the food and
drink cannabis infused products
otherwise yes everything that's under
cannabis products might just point me to
where in the bill i'm looking for the
subtraction representative ames might be
able to do that better than i can
because i was trying to find it and i
was struggling to he he went through and
did a really in-depth this is where
we're prohibiting
so if he would like to answer i think he
might be better
i'll give it a try i wasn't ready for
this uh
the what i
tried to point to were the various parts
of the
bill just as you are
that relate to this question and
we i started with the exclusion
from the definition of cannabis so this
is defined at page 2 lines 26 to 7
and excluded from cannabis is the weight
of any other ingredient
combined with cannabis to prepare
topical or oral administration's
food drink or other product
so there's one provision we have to keep
in mind
the second is the possession limit which
i think you
fingered um
and in that case it's uh
there are actually two provisions
um
that are
affected by the possession limit
uh and i don't have that language right
in front of me
but you have to look at i think we're
looking then at page 3 line 16 to 19.
i've got 19 to 22. 19 years ago that's
the prohibition piece that we're
cleaning up
and then uh
that that possession limit is
operationalized
um in
the provision that allows for personal
use of cannabis which is at page four
and finally there's the definition of
cannabis products
which is on page three at line ten and
that is a definition that includes
quote edible products ointments and
tinctures
and finally
there's the
language at page 12 lines three to four
that says that shall be the duty of the
commission to buy and have in its
possession cannabis for sale
so i flagged all of these i didn't offer
a solution
i sent them to representative lying
saying i think there's a lot of
confusion here i'm confused and uh
it
if you go forward with an amendment i
think you should try to address all of
these provisions i think he's done that
i think what we should do is look at the
amendment and see see how it works
well thank you representative james i
think we need to now look at the latest
amendment which is
which is not the
amendment coming
but it probably has everything
except for
the definitions correct so the current
bill that's coming in i or the current
amendment that come that's coming in
deals with the what edible is and making
sure that it's clear that those food and
drink items are not allowed to be sold
in state liquor stores except to medical
clients that's that's what it'll say in
a current in the current language
or in the language that's coming in the
amendment i just asked for this morning
but we could still go through the rest
of the ghosts there's some financial
stuff in here we probably want to talk
about and some of the other changes i
took out the 15 limit on cultivators in
this bill
why don't why don't we go to the
amendment that you just gave us which is
income
which doesn't have the definition
modified and the amendment we're talking
about is
22-1152h is that correct correct that's
the most current one the committee has
that deals with everything we talked to
up to friday and then over the weekend
late friday we had a conversation and
then over the weekend there was some
more stuff that came in i've submitted
an amendment to try to clean that up as
well
let's let's do this right from start to
finish
so represent a line
so i don't know mr j if you want to just
go page by page and just take questions
because again this is i think that might
be the easiest way rather than me try to
point out every single change that's on
here again we talked about most of the
changes that are in here the only one
that that's
missing from friday is the testing which
i've added that that'll be coming in the
in the amendment for coming up let's
so there were no changes this is
original bill language
um
tucker on page one on line 16
wouldn't it be better to
and that's of the amendment right
yes okay
all retail
cannabis stores
and this answers the question
you don't now have it that all cannabis
stores would be run by the state
and if you change 16 to
plural
all
the a would be in all
and stores would have an s on it
if i may so again mr chairman there's a
definition of retail cannabis stores and
on this the next on page
three
and it says a retail cannabis store
retail store means a state operated
facility that purchased cannabis from
cannabis cultivating facilities and
purchased cannabis and cannabis products
from a cannabis manufacturing facility
and sells transfers delivers cannabis
and cannabis products to consumers
so
in order to be
a retail cannabis store it means that
it's a state-owned facility but having
something that's on page one makes it
clear that this is a monopoly
arrangement
in the state of new hampshire that only
the state can sell
have a retail cannabis store
if that's the will of the committee i
can add the word all in front of it but
i think it's what you're driving at
isn't it
so i'm gonna be polite and say that this
is a forward-looking bill some of the
language that was put in here was put in
with the idea of if we want the changes
to a full-blown
forward-looking
private
stores and dispensaries
it's there's only a few sections of this
law you would have to change
i understand that that's why i'm
suggesting that this be very clear
so again if it's the will of the
committee i can i can add the word all
in front of um
all cannabis stores shall be operated by
the state of new hampshire that's the
will of the community i think if you
want a privatized system that's what you
should
be aiming for i think this is
this is transparent clear this is what
we're
all right
uh page two we don't have any changes we
will have changes
coming in
that will deal with the definition of
cannabis to make sure that um
the again the cartridge that what we
were talking about it only it's only
about the food
and drink provisions of that and i don't
know how that'll work out given the
language in section on line seven
um that this font that has a description
of cannabis and in there it talks about
prepared topical oral administrations
food drink and other products that
language is gonna change i'm sure i
don't know exactly how it's gonna change
so any questions on page two or
additions anybody would like to see on
page two again mo this is current bill
language i didn't make any changes i
just know that
based on the conversation we represented
ames there will be some change relative
to again the food and drink conversation
representatives
thank you mr chairman
i i'm not sure if i heard the comments
correctly but there was some suggestion
of perhaps removing the word mixture
which is page two
line nine
and
speaking in general
generally about any type of controlled
substance you it's
usually best to leave the word mixture
in there
in cases
and it comes to really an enforceability
side
from a prosecution side they would have
to
show 100 purity
if you take out the term mixture also if
it's a thc product but perhaps it's
illegally laced with something else you
you can it gets a little complicated
when you deal with specific definitions
of synthetic or other manufactured drugs
that are legal so i would just recommend
for the sake of
not potentially opening a door of
unintended consequences leaving the word
there was i didn't receive any comments
asking to remove that over the weekend
page three mr chair
page three
so
um i agree with somewhere we had a
conversation around here there's no
changes on this bill from the original
bill in here however i do think we need
to have a conversation around
lines 19 through 22
and talking about the fact that
this the idea of cannabis infused
products and making sure we're clear and
understanding what that is the the
purpose of this was basically to say um
that if you have a medical card
this doesn't apply right so this if you
have a therapeutic card um it doesn't
apply we i do know one change is going
to be and again this is at the request
of mr simon is all through here where we
talk about medical marijuana we're going
to change the word the therapeutic
throughout the entire bill i made that
change request this morning
so we're talking about the therapeutic
cannabis and not medical cannabis
because there's in our statute we talk
in our 120 126x statutes we talk about
therapeutic use and therapeutic cannabis
and therapeutic cards so to speak not
medical cards so i'm going to make that
change the entire bill to make sure
we're consistent with other parts of our
rsas
okay
any other questions on page three
represent elneny
thank you with regard to this but
especially future
sections
there is a administrator
for the state medical cannabis program
therapeutic cannabis program oh he's
here
oh
he wasn't speaking up
i think we need to talk with him about
this solution
um representative kirk is trying to find
canarque is trying to find you right now
so
so if i'm not mistaken and he can answer
that my statement is right we talk about
therapeutic use and not medical use is
that
so are you in agreement that we should
change the word medical the therapeutic
in the bill to make it clear so it's
assuming we leave it in but we don't
want to leave it as medical with
therapeutic be the appropriate word to
mr chair there were no changes on page
four unless somebody just has comments
in general about the page or suggested a
subject suggested change questions or
comments on page four
uh representation
thank you mr chairman uh so the top of
page five
uh talks about you know a first fine
being five hundred dollars or up to five
hundred dollars no more than five
hundred dollars
um and a driver's license suspended for
up to three months and then a second
offense and future offenses up to a
thousand dollar fine and up to six
months suspension
my concern would one of my major
concerns with this bill in the beginning
was
driving under the influence
and
this this addresses that except i'm
concerned that there's no
teeth really in this in that a judge
could say and a person could be on their
fifth offense and the judge keeps saying
yeah well you know it says up to so the
person could be fined at zero and they
could be
um
not lose their license so i think there
needs to be some teeth in this i'd like
to see
the second and future offense
putting some lower limit on this so that
it's suspended for at least three months
but up to six and and at least five
hundred dollars and up to a thousand
um there needs to be some teeth in that
because
if a particular judge in a particular
area keeps letting someone off the hook
it's not going to be good
for safety of other drivers if i may mr
chair to respond to that so just
understand that this is not relative to
drugged or drunk driving that's not what
we're talking about in this section this
section is specifically talking about
smoking or vaping in a car so you're not
allowed to smoke or vape in a car and if
you're caught smoking or vaping so even
if you just lit up the joint
and the cop sees your light up and walks
over you'll be guilty of this of this
violation that doesn't mean you're
guilty of drug driving or drunk driving
which has much more severe penalties
associated with it in a different
section of our chapter of law this is
strictly having to deal with smoking or
vaping marijuana products uh in a
vehicle
okay but even in that case where there's
a penalty proposed here
so
to get some uniformity from judge to
judge i would think we still need a
minimum
it's still a problem obviously it's
identified in the bill
so i would lastly i would just say that
this is consistent with our other
criminal statutes where you have a
violation level offense we don't ne
generally specify the hard number it's
it's up you know if you're guilty of a
violation is up to a five uh 500 fine if
you're guilty of a misdemeanor it's up
to a thousand dollar fine so these
this language is consists with other
parts of our law we can change it if we
want but generally that's what we say
you're guilty of a violation with
limited exceptions we put a hard number
and say if you do criminal trespass
you've got to get you you're fined a
thousand dollars right we if you're
guilty of criminal trespass you're fined
up to a thousand dollars and the judge
takes into account all this mitigating
and extenuating and and uh
the one that means worse situations uh
and then sets the fine according to the
individual circumstances of a given
offense
i guess do we know whether anyone can
answer the question has this been a
problem with other things where a
particular judge may keep letting
someone off the hook
i mean is this something that i will
tell you the former police officers and
there was judges i'd like to be in front
of and judges i didn't like to be in
front of but that's just the nature of
jurisprudence
of representative thank you um
mr chairman you know as well as i do
that criminal justice has always set
the judicial penalties
and i can't remember a time that we even
changed their thousand dollar fine to a
250 dollar fine or something like that
uh this is policy from the previous
committee
i agree with thank you mr chair i agree
with representative almi this is a
policy issue policy settled on this
okay
um
further questions on page five
moving on to page six mr chair
page six um there is in the mem and i
requested this morning based on the
conversations we had on line 12 i'm
going to make one word change i'm going
to add it says current the current
amendment says requirements
for the testing of cannabis and this is
regarding what rules the
agency must set and we're going to just
change it to requirements for the
testing of all
is the a new word i'm going to add in
the middle of that
cannabis to make sure it's clear that
all cannabis that's going to be sold to
consumer must be tested for equality and
adulterants and data
other than that on this bill i'm sorry
representative
yes
on i found this letter that was sent to
us from
a2la which a lot of people may not have
opened because who knows what a2la
stands for
but it is the american association for
laboratory accreditation
and they had suggested two things about
testing
the first one uh was defining what a
cannabis testing facility is
and the second one
was um
requirements for testing cannabis from a
facility accredited in accordance with
iso iec
etc by an accreditation body that is
internationally recognized to the
current version of etc to test cannabis
for potency and contaminants
so it's not just potency it's also
whether it's laced with gasoline or
something
so mr chair again if we look at the
entirety of the bill and not just that
one line we talk about regulation of
cannabis um
on number
seven health and safety rules including
regarding the packaging preparation
accounts restricting the use of
to consumers so again we have a
provision that says that as part of the
rulemaking authority they have to take a
look at the health and safety rules to
make sure that these are taken care of
so again we could be more specific if we
want in the bill and be definitive and
say that all that you know
lab testing must be in compliance with
the iso
i don't know without the commissioner
here and or dhhs here although the
gentleman from from the marijuana
medical marijuana program may be able to
answer that um but uh i'd be
a little concerned about putting a
hearts
definition in here not giving the agency
there
the ability to find out we may not even
have a testing facility that meets those
requirements in the state and there's
there's a secondary testing facility
that could do it that misses one
you know iso number or whatever it is so
so again i'll leave it to the committee
to make that decision i'd be a little
hesitant to hard i think we're pretty
clear we want safe marijuana in our
stores
explain i think that contaminants is a
much better word than pesticides
pesticides is a piece of what can
contaminate
and the rules will probably end up
explaining what a contaminant is but
there are a lot of other
there are funguses there
are all kinds of things that could be in
them
including i must admit i lived next to
nigeria for a while gasoline
so representative almi how it number so
we're looking on page six line number
three if everyone wants to read along
number four
isn't it restrict that's what you were
looking at health and safety rules
correct it's line yeah that's like
that's line three
section number seven
um health and safety rules including
regarding the packaging and preparing of
cannabis comma
contaminants
comma and restricting the use of
pesticides that may be dangerous to
consumers does that work for you
uh
well i was thinking just say the use of
ca oh no yeah contaminants right it's
two different things we want to make
sure
that is pesticide is a contaminant
right but i i'm calling a special
attention to that so again
so is that that okay to everybody uh
well
the
the presence of
and
representatives
thank you followed by representative
hatch thank you mr chairman
in respect to the definition of
of a pesticide it it's actually a very
broad definition
it can include even
infused water with like garlic or other
or mint
to repel bugs if you can use that on
your lawn so
pesticides is really it
you want maybe you want to keep it in
but at the same time if you put any
contaminants i think having both of them
might be the way to go
i just remember coming across on a
different issue that's one of the
reasons why we so again if i could
reread that sentence the way i'm
planning on submitting it as an
another addition to this amendment
health and safety rules including
regarding of packaging and preparation
of cannabis comma presence of
contaminants comma and the restricting
the use of pesticides that may be
dangerous to cannabis consumers so i
think that that's the cleanest way to
add that oh
and then
on is there no testing for potency
because this is very important for the
labeling
again if i i i know nothing about the
testing of cannabis so i don't know how
they would test for potency but maybe
excuse me mr chair
aren't we talking policy again versus
yeah i i think
we're treading deeply in that yeah again
representative aaron i think we're
getting close but i also think that if
it's a consumer protection issue and
it's important to this committee i think
we're probably okay again
we talked about the other day it's the
what and the how right so the what is
legalization that was the policy that
was established by the criminal justice
committee now we're getting to the how
that's being done right so i think we're
okay in the how conversation we're not
okay with the what conversation
yeah gotcha and if i could just point
out if we have a reputation for connect
contaminated
product we are not going to earn any
money
i'm not worried about earning money i
want to keep my citizens safe
potency is this the potency question
yeah
oh on the potency my name is michael
holt i'm the administrator for the
therapeutic cannabis program within the
department of health and human services
currently all therapeutic cannabis is
tested by an independent licensed
laboratory in the state of new hampshire
they are allowed to test cannabis only
for the atcs not for other
entities
all
representative ami's comments are
spot-on with regard to um
appropriateness of statutory language
that should be in here uh regarding
contaminants um and uh pesticides and
potency um it would be
it would be strange for the liquor
commission to not establish these
properly in the rule um however
legislative guidance is always
appreciated um when uh when drafting
rules um by putting in words like
potency contaminants pesticides etc i
will say the primary concern that i have
is that
this bill would set up the liquor
commission as the licensing entity for
labs we hhs is also a licensing
entity for cannabis testing
again it's a duplication of regulatory
effort
so mr chair just just to be clear
because i just finished reading through
some of the regulatory stuff so again
under lines 7 through 10 we talk about
labeling requirements of the product
include
mandating disclosure of the thc content
so there's our potency somehow we've got
to get a test to that to know what the
potency is in order to put it on the
label so there will be some testing of
the product to make sure they can meet
all the other provisions again it talks
about the requirements of the package
insurance not designed to appeal to
minors and establishing the amount of
thc that may be included in the serving
of cannabis so again i think that that
definition says in order to meet a which
is mandating disclosure the thc content
someone's got to test it to figure out
how potent this stuff is and how much
thc is in the product so i think
the the testing for potency is already
implied in this bill
okay
representative
yes thank you mr chair the gentleman
from hhs um expressed most of what i'm
concerned about and that's what we turn
over to the agency to develop rulemaking
and
there's some things that i've heard and
i need not add to what he had stated but
we need to be as explicit as possible in
terms of developing or what's going to
be developed in rulemaking so the agency
knows what's
anticipated by the legislature who hands
them this package to develop the rules
for
and if we leave uh
my experience in in the rulemaking
process if we leave a plethora of things
out that we assume will be added to it
it doesn't always happen and there's not
going to be any cross-check to assure
that it does happen just
uh concerns so it sounds like this
discussion has identified these items in
which representative lang is going to
so we can i think we can move on
thank you mr chair
there are no other changes in the rest
of six so i identified two changes we're
going to do right now we're going to add
the presence of can contamination and
make sure the word all is involved in
the testing of all kinds representative
did you have a question well yes
just a suggestion i think in that same
section
roman 10 that you were just referring to
representative lange
why wouldn't you put in requirements for
the testing of all cannabis for
maybe there's an end there i don't know
i can look at that again i think we
added contamination already when we talk
about the health and safety rules i can
look under the labeling requirements
again we have a mandated for disclosure
thc content and i use for each product i
put
as indicated by testing or something
like that so that we know
my thought is that you have a write down
in the requirement for the testing of
all canvas for potency and just but
including potency including potency and
contamination
i was going to concur with that
that doesn't hurt the representative no
i'm concurring with that i mean it
doesn't hurt to add
you know potency
so no other changes on that line so onto
line on page seven
page seven the biggest change in here is
on line three's roman numeral six and
this is where we allow the alternative
treatment centers to have parallel
any questions or comments on that
representation
could we get on
mr holt to come back
and talk to us about
about this
about what he thinks about this
section
he's he's our only
link to
to the group that we're talking about
are we talking about mr simon
or the or the medical medical director
he's the administrative director of the
atcs
do you have a copy of the amendment uh i
do not i have a i have a copy of um
the previous amendment um
i think it's the same language
so for the people in the room the
previous the new amendment version i'll
just read the paragraph so it's everyone
knows what we're talking about says an
alternative treatment center registered
to operate pursuant to rsa 126x
may file an application obtain a
separate registration to operate a
cannabis cultivation facility cannabis
product manufacturing facility a
cannabis transporter pursuant to this
chapter such applicants shall comply
with the same application procedure set
forth in this section and shall be
subject to the provisions of this
chapter if approved the applicant may
operate as as an alternative treatment
uh senator pursuant to rsa 126 axes
and as a cannabis cultivation facility
cannabis product manufacturing facility
and cannabis transporter pursuant to
this chapter as separate entities
what does the department of health human
services
uh opinion on this language um
well i first would say uh we do there
are two atc's here in the room and they
may have comments as well with regard to
the feasibility of this
the
the number one issue that i see i would
say there's two issues primarily one is
that this doesn't provide this language
does not provide a path to for-profit
status and it's unclear whether or not
the non-profit atc's would be allowed to
enter this market without being a
for-profit
an entity the language does say as
separate entities so if that is what is
intended
it's still unclear how one gets to be a
separate entity without a for-profit
conversion
the second issue i see here is that this
requires um a separate physical location
of the at of the cultivation facility um
which we know is a huge uh
well um expense so it's unclear if uh if
the goal here is to allow
cannabis to get into the state-run
stores they would have to build out a
new cultivation facility and wouldn't be
able to use their current facilities i
think lastly
tcp would be concerned about protections
for
the um
the the medical market
to ensure that the atcs would continue
cannabis for the medical market
i understood i i think we heard
testimony yes during friday it was from
from talk about maine where literally
the the intention of this bill was
that you could file a separate company
and on
in your facility you could put a second
greenhouse we talked about yes someone
said that there was a main facility that
literally has this is the medical
marijuana greenhouse this is the adult
use greenhouse and the intention was
that on the same grounds but they had to
have the products separated so the idea
was to allow for that for the atc's to
thank you mr chairman um i think that i
understand what mr holt's saying
that somewhere in here it should say
that the the additional license is a
sure let me give that to ols and see if
they can figure a way of drafting that
the second parallel license will be a
representative
yeah obviously this is something they've
been looking for for a long time to be
able to do that
i'm correct on that correct that i know
we talked about a marijuana commission
but is the issue the way the
atc statutes are written that becomes
problematic
is there something we should be looking
in the atc statutes that needs to be
modified as well
if we do this
one and two it
is it it would be a violation of the
atc's statutes to
to because they can't they can't right
well guess what i'm saying right now
can the the atc
establishments cannot sell the growers
cannot sell to
any other recreation can't sell to
recreation correct
that's correct the current cannabis law
allows the atcs to sell to one another
only only
so to be able to do this we have to
modify the
those statutes as well
the atc statutes i think there's i think
there's quite a bit of work that needs
to be done in order to figure out what
actually
what the mechanism would be to allow
um the atcs to enter this market uh
including a for-profit conversion um
which was the subject of uh the vetoed
senate bill 38 from last session um
including you know the the specific
mechanisms to allow um
sale the issues of duplicate um
regulation overlapping regulation and
most importantly to the the program is
to ensure if an atc entered this market
that there would still be enough
cannabis in cannabis products to serve
the medical population at their atc
stores so i think there's a lot of work
that needs to get done
and how that
and how that would happen um this sets
up a framework certainly
but i think there's a lot of details
that we worked out
and including on potential amendments to
the rsa 126x
so um i i i don't know what any of those
are yeah mr chair can i follow follow
so it sounds like senate bill 38 from
last year may have language
that could be helpful to all us too
so i did specifically bring up to the
drafter anthony the the 126x and i was
concerned there were things prohibiting
that we might have to modify in order to
allow this he said after review that was
not it was not the case this language
alone was all that was needed i can have
him re-follow it up and check again but
he felt that based on statute there
wasn't a reason there may be a rules and
regulation issue that has to be worked
out between the agencies um but by
statute there wasn't any measure
i mean if it says in the atc statutes
that
they can't sell to uh recreational
sites that's pretty but again this is
going to be a separate entity so it
wouldn't be the atc it would be the
agc's for profit organization which
would be different a separate entity in
a separate condition we're not doing it
under the atc's medical license we're
doing it under the for-profit license
that is in there that's allowed by a
different statute
and that's why we also have the issue of
separate facilities is to make sure
again
it's clear this is adult use this is
medical this has certain rules that has
different rules
so which is okay so what you're saying
then what this really does is it allows
a corporate structure
it would one on the other
yeah
i mean
or is it two different corporate
corporations
so i i would i would say it's two
different corporations that they can
apply for apparel open a get it get a
lice get a light you know
atc
again i i i the intention of this and
and in talking to the drafter that this
language would allow them to create a
for-profit organization apply for a
parallel license
be on the same
um
for lack of a better phrase physical
property but same street address but
have separate physical locations for the
for the set to separate the medical
marijuana from the adult use marijuana
and that would meet the terms and
conditions of both this and the atc
requirements roxanna abbas
thank you and this is
a question for anyone in the committee
has the atcs provided any suggested
language or recommendations on how to
draft this provision
and if they haven't i would be
i would urge the committee to call on
matt simon who is here and may have some
more uh detailed uh testimony regarding
this issue
i think it's pretty clear what
everyone's what's trying to be done here
the execution is where the
problem is but i i suppose if the
atc's had any recommendation on that it
would be
thank you mr chairman without having
taken any look at the atc
statutes i don't know whether this would
work but as a parallel entity that's
self-contained and described here
this may be one of those places where
you start with the preferatory phrase
notwithstanding
um
rsa xyz
uh the following will be allowed
so i you know again i'm just suggesting
you representative spillsby
representative ames
i mean almy
do we have anyone here who knows from
the legal side whether you can form a
for-profit corporation that would be
required to hand over all of its profits
to the non-profit which is what they
need
well mr chair
representative i know when i know in
massachusetts a not-for-profit can own a
for-profit
but i think in new hampshire that's not
the case
a for-profit can own a not-for-profit
it's the other way around
and i know that because of a company
that i work for that was a
in massachusetts that was and i had
inquired about new hampshire and it was
totally different it was just the other
way around
so
that's and i don't see anybody else here
that has that answer so i don't know if
that's the correct answer i i think it
is
i guess all i know is that uh
this needs to be done carefully
that
with all respect to the drafter
that uh
using words like entities
um
which is in this amendment
and permitting an alternative treatment
center to make the application
probably doesn't
isn't uh
going to result in the clarity that's
needed
i i do have the
the 126x statute right here
and uh you don't have to go beyond the
second line of the statute to see that
by definition an alternative treatment
center
is a non-profit not they call it a
not-for-profit entity
and so what we'd be writing here is that
an alternative treatment center which
means a non-profit entity
may file an application to obtain a
separate registration presumably in its
name it just
you know there's a logical
scene to me discontinuity here that
would be
that could is eminently fixable it just
requires a little more time and
attention and i don't know whether we
can give it that time and attention but
i'm i'm not necessarily opposed to doing
this
i hear from the alternative treatment
centers that they want to do this
let me remind the com the committee
we need to get this bill out
wednesday morning
i was hoping
that we could get this bill out today
if it took
all afternoon
uh mr simons can you add anything that
thank you chairman for the record matt
simon representing prime atc
we sent this paragraph to attorneys
business law is not my area of expertise
at all so they've asked me some
questions via email i'm hoping to be on
the phone with them this afternoon to
try to
reach some level of understanding here
as it is we have far more
questions and this doesn't seem
sufficient or adequate
as background
several states required medical cannabis
businesses to be non-profit and all of
those states i believe accept new
hampshire has dropped that requirement
and has allowed medical cannabis
businesses to be for-profit
so senate bill 38
created a
system for transitioning
and
allowing atcs to become for-profit we've
suggested all along that should be
included in any adult use legalization
bill
i don't understand how we could operate
two separate entities even if it's
legally
viable it's hard to see it being viable
from a business perspective having to
duplicate efforts in multiple facilities
and higher i i don't know how that would
work
we've talked about it a little bit it
would certainly add costs as opposed to
states that are able to be dual use
cultivators and manufacturers so
my sense is that this isn't going to
work and we'll need further work before
it could be workable but we're working
representative tucker
what you're saying is a one solution
would be to
have this
paragraph
change atc's to
profit-making firms speak under the mic
i'm sorry
so a solution would be to eliminate the
non-profit status of these atc's in this
bill
and just have them
turn into if if they wish to
profit-making
groups
is that correct
i guess i'm asking tim lang
i'm not an attorney so right but i mean
that's what you're talking about that
has been our
rather than going a parallel route
you're saying the solution here
is not to rework a complicated topic but
to change this to allow changing the
status should they wish to
to profit making in order to fulfill the
sort of the trade-off
that they might lose some status and
profit or
cash flow and i also think it's
imperative for our ability to serve
patients and continue serving patients
in a way that's even remotely
competitive with the state-run stores
we've already heard that it'll be
tax-free cannabis and state-run stores
the goal is to undercut the costs of
neighboring states meanwhile the atcs
are required to be vertically integrated
produce all of our own product we can't
buy from anybody else so patients will
have maybe dozens of options at the
state stores they'll only be able to buy
products produced by prime atc or if we
were to buy from one of the other two
atc's at wholesale so you're creating a
much more limited market for medical use
i don't know if there's any way around
that but certainly including the
language of sb 38 would give the atcs
the ability to convert for to for-profit
and
potentially participate in both
markets
and
do so more effectively on both sides so
follow-up a follow-up so
everything i've heard about the
medical side of
is really superior and that you have the
ability to
talk with
people who are users because of medical
reasons in a way that is more like a
patient relationship rather than
a retail store relationship so that's
very important i think to preserve
so you're saying that the best way to
preserve that would be to change this
section six roman numeral six into the
ability to have a non-profit should you
choose
i mean to have a profit making should
you choose
i believe that's correct okay so is that
something that uh you think could be
pursued
representative
so again i think there's a huge policy
change
to making uh atc's um dispensaries
for-profit versus not-for-profit and i
think that's probably way beyond the
purview of this committee to make that
broad determination
what i can do is look at again i'll go
back to the draft and look at language
that talks about not notwithstanding
kind of language that says you know
excluding this chapter of law this is
what you're allowed to do kind of thing
i'll see if we can figure that out and
do something with that because the other
alternative is to strike this language
all together and not even given the
ability to do this uh which i'd rather
not do i think it's a benefit to them i
think it's a benefit to the to the state
um i would rather not strike the
language
and if you know due to time constraints
we get stuck we can pass something with
the intent of what we're trying to do
and take over to the senate and clean it
up
where we do have more time we'll have
another month and a half two months to
work on it
i don't like generally doing that
passing bad bad language over but at the
same point we pass it over with clear
understanding that we need to look at
this section otherwise we strike it we
need to strike number six all together
and just not give them the opportunity
um but i'll look at that i'll look with
the drafter and see if there's a way of
cleaning it up to where it would it
would work but absent that we can just
look at striking it and not even putting
the opportunity in there
it sounds like
that
we pass it over
to the senate
with some language that it needs to be
cleared cleaned up that's what i would
prefer to do as the chairman again i
just i'm we're getting back into the
what and the how conversation what what
is the legalization the how is how we go
about it um this this is a how question
i'd like to give the atc the opportunity
to
to sell to the state that's what this
whole chapter this paragraph is about is
giving them the opportunity if we need
to clean that up i'd rather take it over
the senate clean it up versus kill this
bill right it's a policy so yeah
if i made this comment briefly
if the bill were to come out
forbidding the atcs to participate in
this market
i would just argue that it's also a very
large policy change to license
potentially dozens or hundreds of
businesses that would be for-profit in a
space where there are already three
existing businesses that have to be
non-profit so
if you want to build that people are
very unhappy with that's
stopped my intention that's why i put
the language in that's not my intention
so i i'd like to see it okay
matt matt
so senate bill 38 did that pass both
houses
yes it passed the house and senate it
was vetoed by the governor uh it the
senate overrode the veto 19 to five
and the house was two votes short of
that override
and if you look at the governor's veto
statement i believe i included in my
emails
he specifically mentions the idea of
having regional for-profit monopolies
and the concern that if they went for
profit prematurely that it would give us
an unfair head start
and i'm arguing that this is the
opposite you'd be giving hundreds of
businesses potentially an unfair head
start and leaving us in the dust and
that's
the governor's veto statement flipped on
its head thank you for that that's a
good answer thank you
representative
thank you i'm not uh
i don't know what
what the house would do this year since
was that wasn't last year was it was the
year before
it was vetoed in august and the
the votes were in january
okay so so we've got the same people
we have an almost two-thirds in the
house we have a two-thirds in the senate
that went along with this
this solution
except the governor and the governor
vetoed it because
we didn't have
marijuana legalization i don't see
that
why we can't include that bill
or the operative parts of it into this
bill
and have it go forward since the
governor's on object if the governor is
willing to sign legalization he should
be willing to sign this part of it
as well
i mr chair if i may i just be concerned
that we start going the non-germane
areas if we open up all kind if we
change the atc's and try to do that to
make them all for profit the
either the speaker or someone may argue
that it's a non-german amendment not
that wasn't included in the original
bill to go start changing 126 and so i'm
a little bit nervous about that um that
we get it killed for some other stupid
reason when we have a path forward right
here
we're not going to
solve this right now
so we have to make a decision
do we make a small tweak on this and
move forward i will mr chairman
i will mr chair okay
the other thing is uh we have somebody
from the bankers association who wants
sorry thank you um for the record ryan
hale vice president government relations
for new hampshire bankers um while this
is not a banking issue we just thought
that might be helpful for the committee
we as an association are non-profit but
we do operate a for-profit
we thought that might be helpful for the
for the committee
okay
short of counting on the thank you mr
chair sure coming i i would agree and
suggest that we strike section six
the
the suppliers that we're trying to
include here can apply like any other
entity that wants to be a cultivator
okay and we lose this headache
i'll do mr joe i'll just take i'll take
on the tweaks that that of trying to
make the language work because i do
think we want to be fair to the atcs and
not give them an undue delay in this
process and i'll just bring it i'll
bring it to the committee and we can
decide i am nervous about either we have
to strike the language because i don't i
don't think we should go deep into 126
and try to change chapters of law
they're not already brought up in this
in this bill and specifics like making
atc's for-profit organizations so i i
rather not do that but i'd rather do
just kind of tweak the language we have
and we can move over to the senate and
then if they want to add it it'll follow
the senate process and they have every
right to add the 126 language to make
atc's profits from senate bill 38.
represent abbas
thank you mr
chairman when i first introduced the
bill
a few weeks ago
i was i'm supportive of having some type
of partnership with the atcs
but it's it's a complicated integration
and i would say that without having any
suggestions or even suggested language
it makes that partnership
extremely difficult
and i i understand that a lot of people
are concerned about
what potential negative impact 1598
would have on the
atc's there been any information
presented to the committee about the
percentage of
customers that the atcs would
potentially lose
to if there was a retail
canvas store and i guess what was the
basis of arriving at that conclusion and
the other question really is
you know how much a percentage of the
sales would the atc's have to lose
before their viability actually came
into
question i'm not sure if that was
provided to me i understand that there
may be a competing market share to some
degree but
i'm just without seeing the the business
model itself i wouldn't know
the details of that
we don't know and we don't have the time
to find
the administrator of the atc
he doesn't have the answer so mr i think
probably the important thing we heard
was from the banking industry that you
could have a not-for-profit entity that
also owns a for-profit entity and i was
thinking of concrete capital region
healthcare when i worked for them we had
some medical practices we owned that
were for-profit medical practices that
were owned by capital region healthcare
so i know
you can do that there are some tax
implications of those kind of things but
i also realize we can do that
i think we need to move on thank you
so next comes the fun the real reason
ways and means is here we're talking
about disbursement of funds and
collection of funds and what that looks
like we're still on page sorry where am
i here
uh we moved on from page seven
there's no changes in the rest of that
page and we move on to page eight
um on page eight the first thing the
first changes that were made as part of
the amendments was the banking language
which i presented to you guys last week
um it said it starts on pay uh page 8
line 18
and mainly we talk about just some
financial protections and like the
monies that that the uh the funds shall
be kept distinct and separate from all
the other funds in the state treasury
and the monies credited to the fund
shall be held distinct and separate from
all other funds over which the state
treasurer has control monies in the fund
shall be deposited in a financial
institution as defined by the rsa with a
branch in a state so again this is just
some financial protections we put into
the bill
to protect the state in case the federal
government comes in we didn't want
liquor to intermix cannabis money with
liquor money and then have the state the
feds come in and decide they're going to
take all of our money and and so it was
just a little bit of protections put
then we get down to
[Music]
line 32 which is where we start talking
about disbursement of the money
uh the revenues that do come in from the
cannabis fund and deposit into the
cannabis fund
um
as i said on friday the first thing this
amendment does is i inverted um the um
payback to the citizens
with the operational expenses for the uh
agency in other words the agency has to
be able to operate first and then we
start paying back the citizens um the
4.6 million dollars i also put um
a deadline in number four for the
payback so number number three on line
is um the administration allowing them
to take the administration out of the 30
million dollars
and then number four is the payback and
i gave them a five-year payback with the
idea being that the first three years
they're going to be in a pretty
significant growth mode and then the
second two years they should have enough
revenue coming in that to be able to pay
our citizens the 4.2 4.6 million dollar
startup costs that we allocated for them
any questions on
moving on to page 9. this is where we
start talking about the net net revenues
meaning that after we've taken out the
costs and after we've paid back the
citizens how much money is left and what
are we going to do with that money
um
so i'm going to run through it i'm
hoping i get through the the five
sections that are here about how the
money's dispersed and then we'll have a
big just a conversation in general about
disbursement so the first one is 50 will
be sent to the department of revenue to
offset swept property tax
so the so as explained i think on friday
currently by statute we have to raise
363 million dollars
um to for swept and that's what that's
the direct taxation we do to our
citizens
um if we're going to do this i felt we
need to give our citizens a good reason
why we're doing this and one of the and
the swept property tax reduction was one
of the ways
um in that um
if we raised 363 million dollars and 50
percent of the money we got was 10
million dollars we would then only have
to raise 353 million dollars from our
citizens we directly offset the
statutory obligation uh the 363 million
which would result in a
the line item on your property tax bill
it says statewide education property tax
being lowered
for every citizen every taxpayer so
that's the first one first disbursement
the second disbursement is um 30
of the remain of that net net
is uh going to
reduce the
um
new hampshire retirement system debt we
certainly have a we currently have a
debt of i believe it's around 6 billion
that the state owes to the retirement
system
the idea is we would help
hasten that pay down
by hastening that pay down this will
directly affect towns once it's paid off
so the faster we can get it paid off the
faster all of our towns and our
communities will be benefited because
our rate that we charge the towns is
increased because we have to pay the
debt off so once we pay the debt off
that percentage we need to collect from
the towns
will be less
and to the employ to every single state
employee the number will be less so the
percentage that's charged as the to the
retirement system for them for their
retirement would go down which means
that every single state employee would
basically see a pay raise beyond just
debts paid off so the faster we can do
it the better it is for everybody we pay
less interest on the on the funds so
that's why that line was added in there
question
when you mention the state employees is
that a negotiated uh
retirement
percentage they have to pay in
so it's not negotiated it's part of the
retirement systems when they do their
fiscal audit and maybe somebody from
fiscal could answer this question better
than me or edna ran this language by the
chairman of edna and they said with this
one piece of language we got every
committee vote from over in edna because
the next one is 10
um or
25 million dollars whichever is less to
be credited the department of health and
human services for drug and alcohol
services for use for evidence-based
voluntary programs for substance abuse
so again we the idea is as the program
ramps up in theory there are more and
more citizens using it in theory dhhs
needs more and more money to deal with
more and more citizens so we we did a a
10 number rather than a hard number um a
best especially with a hard number of 25
million dollars because we don't even
think the program's gonna make that in
the first year so it automatically get
you know we bankrupt the money so the
agency so by using a percentage and
allowing it allows as the agent as it
grows to go in there i will send i
apologize i think i said i was gonna do
this on friday but i'll do it before i
leave i do have an email from dhhs about
all their other cessation programs
remember as part of the opioid crisis
and the settlement there's some money
that's going to go into the cessation
program there's a significant amount of
money that goes into the cessation drug
and alcohol association programs from
liquor money as well
i did have the disbursement uh i i asked
liquor i asked dhhs to give me on all
your alcohol and drug cessation programs
what are your source of revenues what is
the expenditures you've made how many
citizens have you helped and i'll
distribute that out to all the committee
members so you have it
after that we put five percent remaining
to disbursement of public safety
agencies including police fire and
rescue agents for the hiring and
training of additional drug recognition
experts so again this is money that
would go to law enforcement and first
responders to help with any any
implications that re
result out of this and i use the example
of this is when i was a police officer i
was a dre i was a drug recognition
expert
and it made it so that if i stop
somebody which i have for driving when i
thought they were drunk and it turned
out they were they were actually it
wasn't alcohol it was a drug related um
stop and an impairment
it gives cops tools to be able to better
articulate in their police reports to be
able to get convictions better so they
understand exactly what they're looking
for and how to articulate what they
found
better to allow us to be able to get
convictions on these things
so um so again there's there's language
in there to give law enforcement and
first responders the training they need
to be able to
deal with our drunk dr drugged and drunk
driving issues better
the last one um maybe representative
abbas can answer why this year but it's
in here was asked and i agreed i agreed
with it this five percent remaining will
be dispersed to the department of health
and human services division of
behavioral health bureau of child
behavioral health to be used for
children's behavioral health services so
again there are implications and i'm
guessing this goes back to
the to 10 we're just talking about the
substance abuse issues there are related
issues with families that have issues
and this would be able to help those
families and the children of those
families
so that's the money disbursement so now
we can have that conversation
okay we have two members from the
finance committee sitting with us today
yes the uh
current liability is 4.99 billion
and which was you know i mean it's it's
been up to 5.4 when we changed it in
when uh it uh
we we've been reducing it but the people
that are currently on retirement and
those
shortly because our our workforce is
obviously
aging out and uh that's going to come
due here very quickly
so that's it's important we get that
under control
uh
i think that's about it uh
yeah
that's
in hats you have any comments um
yes thank you mr chair though um
the mannerism in what some of these
items are being
funded as well without is not without
precedence
for example the alcohol fund
when it was established
there was to be a certain percentage i
think it was
of alcohol
state liquor store revenues to be
dedicated to alcohol and drug abuse
mitigation
though we went many decades without
sending them any money
that was
the methodology used for funding
that type of activity
my only concern is and and it may or may
not be unfounded is i'm looking at the
specific amounts
and how much is there for example the 25
million that caught my eye
um without any knowledge of
what's planned what's being done and i
guess representative lang asked hhs for
what's currently in place
and i think
and we i know we're short of time in the
dynamics of this it could change in the
senate um i'm just not comfortable with
the amounts without
a little more information and whether
there's time or not to have that
hard to say
have asked hhs for some information john
has has given us some
but
today his only response or hhs only
response is they
they really didn't request the funds um
they're
aware that they are in the
bill but they have no input on to what's
appropriate how much is needed and what
should be done and i'm i'm just
we're you're marking a considerable
amount and a considerable percentage
percentage and i'm just not sure
that may be very perfect but that's not
how we normally do things and i'm just
not sure that's a good idea
thank you representative hatch and
further questions representative elmi
yes thank you
on
you're talking i believe about
the
ten percent
on
for quite a long time to come
that's going to be three million dollars
a year
but it does seem there is a
program already in
hhs uh in
the bureau of drug and alcohol services
and uh
that is supposed to be
providing
uh this kind of help for addiction and
it seems to me that
on we
it probably
if
mr holt knows what the name of that
program is it probably should be just
put in there
to add to the little bit of money that
we feed into addiction work
from various sources we've done it a few
times with gambling bills we've
on
page nine on i believe that that
representative hatch was talking about
the
or 25 million dollars whichever is less
credited to the department of health and
human services
actually
uh
yeah thank you mr chairman uh one of the
things that
representative lang pointed out was the
swept tax
if you remember earlier in the year we
voted on to reduce the swept tax by a
hundred million dollars
which goes directly against property
taxes which is a big problem in the
state so this
this is going to uh
parallel that uh effort
uh that's only for that hundred million
dollar uh
that that is only for this year uh
and that's going to be paid uh for
anyone who wants to know is uh with part
of adequacy in the fall to the schools
[Music]
so again
to that point on what representative um
petrie was just talking about again this
was the hundred million dollars was a
one-time ex one-time expenditure and so
the goal here is to if we're going to do
something for the purpose of the
citizens let's provide a permanent
path of relief for them as well so this
creates a funding source settle annually
while it may be variable and with the
with with all good luck it's going to go
up year over year that'll allow for a
slow reduction of the required property
tax to be collected by our citizens
under this swept line on your property
tax bill
so it gives a funding source whereas the
other funding source was just because we
well the first thing i want to say is i
think it's foolhardy to have a list like
this in a
piece of general legislation where we're
we're allocating uh by percentage
uh
potentially substantial amounts of money
to
what uh
at this moment in time or favored by the
majority of
of a committee or of the house or at the
house and senate
uh this this is what we have a budget
process for this is uh
the budget process is designed to sort
out needs against uh revenues and
here we're trying to lasso to
capture
uh what could be 30 million or or it
could be 100 million dollars
and steer it into
several several different categories
maybe five or six i don't have the count
here
so that's my first point i just think
it's foolhardy and
i wouldn't do it i i would
say that the bill that came to us had
one favored category
up front and that was a category that
directly related to what this
bill was concerned with addressing which
was cannabis and the use of cannabis and
maybe more generally the use of
drugs that can be addictive
and
for that
the bill that came to us
has a 25 million dollar
up front uh allocation
and it's only after that
that
that there are allocations to other
needs
that priority makes sense to me
that's the kind of thing that should be
a bill like this that's the way the
alcohol fund was done
uh up front there was an allocation a
draw from
from
the
source of the alcohol fund
for a specific need that related
to
alcohol
so
25 million dollars or less or more that
that makes sense to me but the rest of
it
does not i would put the rest of it
myself
into the general fund or the education
trust fund take your
take your pick
that's the way i would do it with regard
to the
swept i would simply put
point out
that when you allocate money when you
send money out
uh in effect
to replace
i guess that's how you do it to replace
uh
funds that are currently
derived from the swept
you're sending it
out
in a way that will be inversely
proportional
almost directly to the property wealth
of
each town
the wealthiest town will get the biggest
dollar amount
which will then be applied to their
school budget
which means that uh that town will be
benefiting substantially more
than the poorest down whether it's
i said i see my friend over there
charlestown which is either one or two
at the bottom
or claremont next door to charlestown
uh and on the other end of it we'll have
portsmouth or
mirai or uh maltenborough i
hate to pick out towns but
but uh
we're where the differences are
extraordinary
and so you'll be spending sending much
more dollars much more in the way of
dollars
in effect back through the budgeting
process at the local level the school
funding project process
and i i doesn't make sense to me frankly
uh i can understand cutting the swept
rate at
a general level that
that's uh something we could discuss but
uh
in effect
i
that doesn't make sense to me so those
are three different points
uh and uh those are my uh
feelings that as drafted i i i don't see
how i could support this
mr chairman
representative
thank you so you know representatives
thank you for your comments i i actually
thought long and hard over this over the
weekend that conversation i guess the
way i looked at it was this
was
the bottom line is your your your swept
tax rate
is based on the amount of money that
needs to be raised by the state so if
it's 363 million dollars it's 363
million dollars divided by the total
evaluation of the state gives you the
per thousand costs that we're gonna have
to raise for taxation now if you own if
if the savings by this is a penny per
thousand
and you own a hundred thousand dollar
house you're going to save a hundred
dollars under
yeah i guess a hundred dollars on your
tax bill
if you own um
a 300 000 house yes you're gonna get
three times the savings your tax is
going to be lower but it's the same
percentage of per thousand cost
and that's how the swept property tax
works so this fairly well while i
understand he's
conflicting towns with taxpayers and i'm
talking about taxpayers right every
taxpayer will see a reduction
on this on this model
so
the the amount of taxes collected by the
town will be different right so again if
if this greek creates a reduction of a
penny in the tax rate
then
every citizen will see a penny reduction
in that tax rate it doesn't matter
whether you're from a rich town or a
port town the individual taxpayer is
going to see a reduction and again if i
was looking at this as going forward and
we know from every one of us when we go
to a public setting then probably the
number one thing we hear about is taxes
how are you lowering my property taxes
what are you doing to lowering my
property tax so here's an opportunity
for us to do a permanent solution for
lowering property taxes by creating a
revenue stream that will lower the
amount of money that the state has to
collect from every single property owner
in the state so that's the reason i did
it i i i don't unders i don't want to
confuse
taxpayer in towns we're talking about
taxpayers right this individual citizen
not the governmental organization right
every individual citizen who owns
property in the state of new hampshire
will see their rate for the swept go
down because we're providing a direct
funding source
to reduce the amount of money we're
representing ames then i'm going to let
go just be brief but
for the taxpayers
the taxpayer has two lines on his or her
bill
one is the local school tax and the
other is the swept tax
the school district that the town is
part of
develops its budget and then applies it
and gets revenue for it
by looking to both of those sources
as well as state aid of course
which may come from
from other state funds and uh
if the swept source goes down
then
the
school tax rate is likely to go up
uh and in my town of jeffrey
the swept rate is going down
this
the local school rate is more than going
up is more than countering that so for
for many towns that are poor
property poor
like jeffrey that's what's happening
it is
it is the taxpayer we should pay
attention to the taxpayer but it's
playing out
in a different way and it gets
it's largely because of the differential
okay
represent aaron then repton abbas
thank you mr chair and i'll just be
brief um with regard to some of the
comments from representative ames
um
as we as we sort of divvy up the
pot of money here fifty percent thirty
percent and in in in
trying to consider maybe to give a
little bit more flexibility with how
those funds are divide up maybe we can
insert
say
up to 50
of remaining funds or up to 30 percent
of remaining funds could be disbursed so
that gives a little bit of flexibility
of where
monies might be targeted in any given
um
year where money being dispersed
because yeah maybe we don't want to have
a concrete
50 goes here well maybe that year you
only want to put
so if we add the term up to for each i
don't i'm just putting that out there to
be you know as as a consideration
representative
thank you mr chairman
in respect to the issue of property
taxes
and i'll ask this representative ames if
you can explain
how would we ever reduce property taxes
anytime you reduce the property tax rate
it's done on a percentage based on the
value of the assessed house
so
anytime you would reduce it i guess the
rationale you're providing i'm hearing
is
there's really no way to reduce property
taxes because it would be dispro people
would disproportionately benefit from
that
but
so i guess
i'm trying to figure out how we reduce
taxes for the people who need it because
people keep saying rich communities
wealthy communities
salem where i i
rep that's the district i represent
rockingham district 8.
there's some million dollar homes in
salem then there's homes that are for
sale for three hundred thousand dollars
there's a very large range we can't pick
and choose which houses
or which property values we want to give
a break to which ones we can't that
in of itself would have a discriminatory
impact
so
how do we get around that how do we
solve the property tax issue in the
state
if
you feel it's not you want me to respond
just very briefly just take a moment
i think that the uh
property taxes is uh what is levied to
pay for certain services and in the case
of swept it's levied
uh to help pay for
education
and it it therefore is a function of
the determination by those who are
to
levy taxes to i
establish the uh budget that the taxes
will be based on
um
uh the property tax is a function of
that
it's a function of and so and it's also
a function of what general state aid
comes to the
uh in this case we're talking about
schools it comes to the school district
and so if there's more state aid from
other sources then the property tax can
go down assuming
the budget has been set by the
school committee
so yeah the property tax can go up or
down and i said if we want to provide
more school aid
to to
to fiscally strapped towns we can do
that that's been done a lot in the past
and that has produced uh
property tax decreases in some cases not
all because sometimes the
school needs as assessed by the local
school committee
still are going up so you know it's a
function of determining how much we want
to spend on a particular service more
than anything else and then the values
of individual
homes play into how much is going to be
paid by each particular taxpayer
i don't know whether that answers your
question it's a little bit rambling i'm
sorry
but uh
reubson spillsboard
thank you mr chairman
representative ames uh
has prompted me
in space of just a few minutes to think
hard on this
and
it puts a spin on something i felt on a
gut level when i read the amendment and
that is
that we had made such a radical swing in
the formula
of hp 15
98 the way it was
passed by the house
to the way the amendment is
it was i was trying to sort of how did
we go from 25 million up front to
drug uh issues and 90 of the risk to
education
flipping over to this
that radical shift
was unsettling because it sort of
highlights
that fundamentally it's an arbitrary
allocation i mean we all have to agree
to it
and send it back to the house florida to
to get the house's concurrence but
representative ames has
focused us
on a parallel question we've been saying
as we discussed this
we're not the policy committee we're the
revenue committee well by the same token
we're not
the spending committee
and he's suggesting that the spending
decisions be
left
for
future biennial consideration in the
course of the budget
and i hadn't thought of that
i think it's an extremely powerful point
frankly if i was an appropriator
i would rather
see uh comparable funds
uh going back to restoring at least in
part fiscal capacity disparity aid
and i was a co-sponsor of hb 608 last
year that didn't get out of the
education committee and would have done
that so
these you know that might just be my
personal preference but that's a
discussion that probably
and just
so we do have two members of finance
committee and representative hatch
wanted to like
everybody yeah yes thank you mr chair
and i guess i guess i was trying not to
be quite as blunt but i'd like to thank
um
representative ames for his thoughts
because they coincide with mine
um
in finance
we appropriate and we do that after a
thoughtful
discussion and research of what's being
asked and what's being asked is often
for specific items
now i did mention that something like
this is not unprecedented
the alcohol fund initially was funded
like that but just to give an example of
my thoughts
our
legislative aide our
mr hoffman
he's one of the ones that assist us in
division one and gains information for
us
and here's the question i asked them
last week
or even before that when i saw this bill
do you know of any other circumstance
where funding
of this magnitude was arbitrary
without end user having input and and
that's that's important because
how we determine what funds are needed
for where
in this state um it's all of our monies
is the end users meaning the department
that are
tasked with the responsibility of
whatever we dictate they need to do
comes to us
they have a budget
they speak to that budget the reason for
that budget and then we go from there
and then we decide what should or
shouldn't be done
now
i think it also should be noted that um
i i stated that we had the elk
alcohol fund
that was not funded for many for a
couple decades not one penny of
state liquor store revenues went into
the alcohol fund um there was other
methodologies where that was funded
so what happens in reality we can have
all this stuff
planned and put in
for future budgets to consider
but what can happen and what does happen
is i heard somebody mention that earlier
notwithstanding
and so in reality what happens in
finance and it's just true
that for example when the alcohol fund
came up there was not the money there to
fund it completely so we simply state
notwithstanding whatever rs rsa dictates
that that must be done
is suspended or whatever terminology is
appropriate or cut
so
i don't think
there's i don't like any part of this
because it's contrary to how
this state funds its different
responsibilities
but again
some things in there
that was mentioned for example
using it to for hhs to address
addiction problems is certainly
appropriate because there's a concise
nexus between
what's the activity
and the results and what it may produce
a need so
i really can't support this as it is and
that's
most of the reasons why thank you mr
chairman
thank you representative
representative romney representative
hatch
uh thank you for that uh so
what you're saying it really doesn't
matter what we put in here
because come next budget cycle
hb2 comes into play
and
and some of this
may survive and some of this may not
survive
i was just giving you a it matters i
believe right everything matters but i
was just giving you a historical summary
of what does happen what can happen
and undoubtedly at some point will
happen
it's not without merit to have it there
it doesn't mean it won't happen i guess
it was the will of the original bill
it's good to start with that yeah
okay
representatives
i can explain the rationale behind the
property tax relief
other than the obvious that's one of the
complaints i hear the most from
constituents
the thought process was if the state's
going to engage in a retail enterprise
and make a which i hope a significant
amount of revenue that was one way of
giving the revenue back to the people
and that was the exact rational i had
and
if future legislators want to change
that they can do that whether it's
through hb2 or
separate legislation i know i wouldn't
support to remove the property tax
reduction and i would
argue heavily against that
any further
representative
thank you mr chair
again
i go back i'm still struggling with the
concept that if we reduce the swept tax
other taxes go up because if you
understand the way the swept tax is done
and what it's used for when this town
collects as a swept tax which i think in
my first term on ways of means my couple
a few years ago um i found out i always
thought i paid that and the town sent a
check to the to the state it's statewide
property tax the state gets a check i
write i write a check to the town the
town takes the state portion sends it to
the state that's not what happens
actually state never sees that money
that money is used as an offset to state
out to state aid so when it when the
state looks at education they go hey
this town deserves x dollars in state
aid for all of based on the kids and
everything else that has in the school
district the town the state nets that
against the swept tax that the town
collected so if you do 110 million you
only collected 100 million you get a
check for 10 million dollars from the
state you keep the 100 million you
already collected that's how it's done
right so even if there's a reduction in
what we collect from the citizens the
state still makes that up on the other
side in this case we're making it up
through the way of
this tax on marijuana this this 50 of
revenue going to marijuana that's how
the swept tax works
is that it's the net difference between
what the town collects and what the
state what the state owes you for
education adequacy and you get the
difference now
the interesting part was if you collect
too much
you get to keep that the state makes
that up for we give the money to the
towns that are short
so again if you're a property rich town
you even if we reduce this you're going
to get less money however
you're won't do that money anyway
because you over collected the swept tax
from what your adequacy aid or state aid
was
so again i only see this as helping
every taxpayer
every single taxpayer in the state will
see on their specific the line the only
line we control in here where we
directly tax citizens and
that's that's the line we can manage
everything else is based on local
control and local taxes so um
i i i support this if as representative
uh i think was nunas just said if we're
gonna make a profit we should and we're
entering a retail agency we should
directly give the citizens the profits
back as in in a percentage
and i think that that's what this does
and i strongly support keeping this
language again we're entering into an uh
a
new revenue stream um i do notice that
and i don't think i mentioned it in
section two we give that 30 to the new
hampshire retirement system once that
debts off all of that money goes into
ham just a generic education trust fund
once that debt's paid off so we are
ultimately going to give money just to
generic education costs
that will allow for increases but first
let's pay down our debts before we give
further comments
then
i think we're going to take a break for
lunch
is
time
representative lyon has some new and new
information
thank you mr chairman thank you so i got
the first draft of an amendment back but
obviously we made more some minor
changes today which i'll have to submit
for another amendment which i'm hoping i
can get because it's all just like
adding the word all and adding for
potency under the testing and some minor
word changes so i'm hoping we can stick
around get that amendment back and vote
today but that being said i need to tell
you what the language says for the other
things so when we were talking about
dealing with the edibles
what the ols did was they changed the
definition of cannabis products which is
what the liquor liquor commission is
allowed to sell as cannabis products and
cannabis products are defined now as
means concentrated cannabis products and
cannabis products that are compromised
of cannabis and other ingredients and
are intended for personal use such as
but not limited to creams ointments and
tinctures
for the purpose of this paragraph
cannabis products shall not include
cannabis infused food or drink products
including but not limited to cannabis
infused edibles such as candies gummies
brownies cookies or cannabis infused
alcoholic or non-alcoholic beverages of
any kind so that's the new definition
basically it says they can sell
everything cannabis but food and drinks
so
um
so is everybody kind of okay with that
language that that language if i'm going
to send it back in for an amendment i
want to make sure i'm not because i got
a couple of those couple word languages
could you read it one more time sure
cannabis products means concentrated
cannabis products and cannabis products
that are compromised of cannabis and
other ingredients and are intended for
personal use such as but not limited to
creams tinctures and ointments
for the purpose of this paragraph
cannabis products shall not include
cannabis infused food or drink products
including but not limited to cannabis
infused edibles such as candies gummies
brownies or cookies or cannabis infused
alcoholic or non-alcoholic drinks or
representative ames
i think that's a good definition however
line 11
has the duty to buy and have in its
possession cannabis for sale
in the manner provided in this title
so
how cannabis products plays into this
equation
uh remains to be answered and
i don't
maybe you've got the connection figured
out but i don't
don't say so you're looking at section
3a
yes
that's good shall be the duty of the
commission of buying heavens possession
cannabis for sale i can just again
basically the authorization i can just
add i could add the word products after
that just say cannabis products because
that's we just defined it yeah
again that's why i'm asking because if
there's a change there we need to with
the exception you'd have to say
duty to have cannabis products for sale
except as allowed for therapeutic
um
you know the the exception that you have
elsewhere in there for the uh
those that have a card
okay
so that was page nine
line
so i was page 11 representative
dick
i don't know products
representative romney has a question for
you okay i'm listening
so so we we're
we're still going to allow medical uh
therapeutic people with their cards and
to buy
or do we take that out
the way i would understand it is that
the authorization of the commission
liquor commission would be
to sell
product
and also to
have a have an exception built right in
there that allows them to sell
to the uh
the customers of the therap alternative
treatment centers who have cards
right so that so you've got to build in
the exception somewhere if you're going
to have uh the limitation well at one
point we thought about maybe taking that
out
but i guess we didn't
sounds like but in that case they can
they can have the edibles they could
have the jelly beans and all that
let them finish typing yep so i what i
put was um
in that authorization section we have to
make sure we're allowing them to sell
cat
to sell cannabis in other words cannabis
products allowed by the statute as well
as the therapeutic cannibal process
products allowed by 126x
for persons with cards
does that answer your question
yeah well then just it just puts the
atc's in direct competition with the uh
within these state stores that's all
when it comes to those products so the
interesting part about those products
especially if i may mr chair yes is
especially on the
edible side the gummies that will be
allowed in the state liquor store are
severely under
uh their grade i won't say grade but
their potency is significantly less than
what you can get in a distribu
atc
so it's it's to give basically
short-term relief but not if you want
your regular high your regular
grade you know whatever it does for you
you're going to need to go to a medical
store to get it otherwise the stuff you
buy from the state state store is going
to be pretty watered down
but i think i think mr chair
i think the way it works is the problem
is regulating what's how much
concentration there is in each
brownie or cookie or whatever
is you eat two cookies instead of one
that's that we struggle with that and
the commission how do you how do you
regulate how much thc
uh and
and that that's what happens people will
just eat more
to get to a higher level
but i i that's not a it's a policy thing
i think i'm just throwing that out and
that's the same thing as smoking two
joints so mr so mr chair moving on the
other change was around the therapeutic
centers being able to license
and they changed that to me give me one
second
let me find it again
there we go
all right the new language reads um an
alternative treatment center
regis
well it's not on it's this is the bill
this is the amend the first amendment i
got from this morning when i sent it to
him so i'm going to send it back but
where is it
it's roughly we're on i think it's page
seven i think yeah yeah so but this
language is going to be different it's
going to read
an alternative this is that section six
we thought about deleting if we didn't
want to give the alternative centers the
chance to manufacture and cultivate
the new language reads an alternative
treatment center registered to operate
pursuant to rsa 126x may file an
application to obtain a separate
registration to operate a cannabis
cultivation facility in cannabis product
manufacturing facility a cannabis
transporter pursuant to this chapter
such applicants shall comply with the
same application process set forth in
this section and shall be subject to the
provisions of this section of this
chapter if approved the applicant may
operate as an alternative treatment
center pursuant to rsa 126x and as a
cannabis cultivation facility cannabis
product manufacturing facility a
cannabis transporter pursuant to this
chapter as a separate entity in a
separate physical location
so again this this would allow them to
although i'm not even sure we need the
separate entity anymore but basically
this would allow them under their
not-for-profit license to be able to
sell to the state if they obtained a
so is that the same language yeah
i still think just as a personal though
if you read that
section if we took out the separate
entities piece
they could run under their
not-for-profit license and what would
require them to do is any money they
made from selling to the state pursuant
to the 126 chapter they would have to
roll back in for the benefit of their
patients
if we just want to remove the separate
entity language
it would allow them to use their current
process of their current facilities
and operate under their current
not-for-profit license but sell it to
the state and any monies that were made
in that transaction would have to be
rolled back into under the 126 section
to their uh patients for the benefit of
their patients is actually what it says
in one twenty six
so
representatives
do you intend to have ols draw that up
that way well i'm asking the committee
if where if we're inclined to do that i
could strike the separate entities in
separate physical locations and just say
they
they can operate under their
not-for-profit license and they can
obtain a license to cultivate
manufacturer for the state
and that would and it but the any
revenues they have pursuant to the
current 126x language says that
it would have to go for the benefit of
the patients their patients
ones that want to leave it the way it is
you want to leave it the way it is with
a
separate entity separate physical
location
that's easy
that solves it
so is everybody does that mean everybody
else is in favor of striking that let
them run under their current
not-for-profit license and to use their
any monies they make to the benefit of
their patients
if you are raise your hand
i'm not sure what that means you can't
okay that's the majority
mr chair i have a question though as a
follow-up to that
so i i thought we heard testimony at the
beginning of hearing this bill that the
atcs were concerned if they couldn't
compete with this market that they would
lose some of their you know customers or
patients to to the state-run stores so
they were looking for a way to have that
competition and one of the ideas was to
allow them to to participate in this
state-run market so
if we're saying the only way you can
participate is to be a non-profit and to
roll your
you know revenues back into your into
your business model as a non-profit it's
not going to be putting them on the same
competitive standing point as as a
for-profit business
so i think we're running into the
original concern it would be unequal and
unfair for two you know different types
of entities to be participating in the
market one would have the ability to
am i wrong is that what other people
heard during testimony or
so
if i may misuse to answer her questions
so again it depends on what you think
the purpose of an atc is right if the
purpose of the atc is to serve their
patients
then what this would do is give them a
revenue stream where they would they
would get an inc they'd be able to sell
to the state for
for more than it cost them to grow it
and then roll that money back in for the
benefit of their patients which is
what's required under 126x
so it doesn't give them a profit no
one's going to write a check to them and
they're going to get profits and
dividends out of this but they're going
to be able to make additional revenue to
help set their true medical purpose
okay
representative
thank you
the trouble with that is that 126x
still exists in its entirety
and
as a non-profit they cannot get the bank
loans to get the capital to expand that
was what they were saying
um
so they would not be able to take
advantage of this and also if they're
allowed to do this here and not allowed
to do this in 126x
um
we will have the latest past legislation
carries but it's going to be very
confusing
representative
yeah i just want to say i agree with
representative army it's really the
reason they want this is really to raise
capital as a for-profit it's a lot
easier than for raised capital they can
sell shares they can do all those kind
of things depending on how they
structure themselves as a for-profit
that's my recollection of the debates
well we had that in the marijuana
commission as well those discussions it
was all about raising capital um and
if they stay the way they are they won't
be able to so if we wanted to double or
triple
their
their capacity to grow
and they want to they want to do it
under those kind of not tents but those
outside under those um
whatever they are
the plastic things or even if they want
to buy more space
the greenhouse thank you
uh the uh
even if they wanted to buy more space to
put lights and buy the lights and all
that they need to raise money
and not for profit yeah you can put some
money back into your thing but i i
i think it's really about raising money
is what they want
mr chair i i guess it'd be the first
time i've ever heard of not-for-profit
in this state can't get a loan
right raising capital through
shares and those kind of things but they
can get loans if they want to expand
their facility they could use the
banking
provisions we've put in here plus
otherwise and the current banking model
that they have be able to get loans to
be able to expand facilities and expand
production they can't get it as a you
know an ipo
so to speak but they could get it
through through
normal banking loan procedures again
this is in theory this is about to the
benefit of their patient that's their
mission is to the benefit of their
patients in the first line of 126x about
them being a not-for-profit for the
benefit of their patients
again
mr chair uh
tim oh i was just parodying what i
thought i heard
that they that the uh atc's the reason
they wanted the atc is can shake your
head up and down or
so i'm not sure where we're at mr
speaker are we getting more confused
yeah so again
my inclination was i don't care which
way we go whether we make it a
for-profit or not-for-profit um the
language that if we were to strike a
separate entity and a separate location
would allow them to use their existing
facilities and do a not withstanding
language on 126x and say that they can
also parallel this and use it to raise
revenue raise their revenue to be used
is this one
so that way if they did that
they could do both and keep the
facilities separate
well if we if if we struck the entity in
separate facilities then they could
currently use their current facilities
and assign a portion of that crop so to
speak to
um to the state sale in a portion to the
medical sale if they had if they had uh
extra so again um or they would have to
open and open another greenhouse and go
get a loan and say hey look we're going
to sell to the state we have a license
to the state we need to build more
cultivation facilities we want a loan
and we're going to pay for it by the
revenues from the state which is be a
normal business operating expense which
they're entitled to deduct out of their
revenues so they could still have access
to capital via loan process as well as
the access to the revenue to be able to
pay for that and to create still profit
thank you mr chairman um i believe that
um
the the members from the atcs that were
here did say
make uh allude to the fact of ramping up
to provide
so i i don't know if they would be able
to hold be able to have the quantity
needed for the state in their current
operation
because i believe their current
operations are limited to what their
if you want to if you want to come and
say
just like to add one thing it is
incredibly hard for cannabis businesses
to get any kind of loan
to spend anything
very difficult don't assume that it's
like any other business because it isn't
if they do if cannabis businesses are
able to get loans it is at very high
interest rates and very very unfavorable
terms
uh putting such entities at a massive
competitive disadvantage against large
for-profit
if you were a businessman
and
you had to deal with this issue
no can i say interject one thing can i
just
let somebody else yes
so
to do plan b or plan c we said the first
thing no the second one do what what tim
said to do
i think
is a starting point but i don't think if
we wanted to do true
uh having them be for-profits
i don't think we have time to do that
between now and
i think it's more complicated
and that that would be something that we
could introduce in the senate um
that's just my thought on it i don't
know
do you tim do you have a sense that the
drafter could come up with something
that's well
what i changed in here was i put
in in the in the first sentence i put
notwithstanding the provisions of rsa
126x meaning that if they prohibit it we
allow it we allow it overrides they
prohibit i so i put notwithstanding rsa
126x an alternative treatment center
registered operate pursuant to 126x may
apply for and may apply
may file an application to obtain a
separate registration to operate as a
for-profit cannabis cultivation facility
cannabis product manufacturing facility
or cannabis blah blah so it says
what's wrong with that i'm okay with
does anybody have any objection to that
okay
what's that is that making
yeah thank you mr chairman was that
language going to make make the atc's
it would mean they would have to file a
separate for-profit entity we've heard
that not-for-profits can own for-profit
entities so they'd file a for-profit
entity underneath the not-for-profit and
they'd be able to raise funds and
capital through that
mr jim if i may follow up
does any does anyone know and
for free to provide any input
do any of the current atc
cultivation facilities on the existing
property have the ability to increase
production
thank you
let's take a straw poll are we
those are in favor
let's go on to another
so um
i believe this make sure i believe that
and mr chair if i recall i have nothing
after
uh 10 because now we're starting to get
into um
wow
10 i didn't have anything
on i don't believe we look through real
quick
page 14. right so i'm sorry but i would
just i didn't when we get to page 11
we're really starting to talk about the
legalization aspect that i didn't touch
any of that language
the last section is on page 14 where i
did change
the amount of appropriation to 4.6
and that's the only change on 14. that's
representative tucker
yes uh representative lang did you make
any changes in your thinking
not necessarily
with ols yet
and changing the allocations
so specifically i think that dialogue or
discussion now that we've all had lunch
so a break might be worth continuing
i'll be honest with you i thought about
what we talked about and i'm not
inclined to my my
my position is i wouldn't want to change
those allocations we've done allocations
like that before it while it's not
common it's also not unique either
i think back to my sports betting bill
14 480 last term
we specifically identified all the
revenue to go to education all of it we
didn't put it in the general trust fund
which we could have done because it's
not a lottery it's not a lottery uh
powerball megabucks those kind of things
which are obligated by our constitution
however we just put lottery as the
regulatory agency so we could have
easily left that as general fund money
but we chose to put that directly to
education so again it's not an uncommon
thing that we do um that we we put
products we put revenue to specific
things
i think if we're gonna you know again
it's my opinion and and
i think if we're going to open this up
and we're going to create a revenue
stream new to the state to give the
citizens what they want remember we're
doing this because 78 of our citizens
want legalization right so that's the
reason we're doing it then i want to
return the profit back to the citizens
if if the state's going to take this
this onus on then whatever we have extra
we should be giving back to our citizens
as a profit share for lack of a bit of
phrase
so can i do a follow-up sure mr chairman
so
i'm quite persuaded that the reason this
bill of his interest to me
is one that the criminal justice
committee talks about which is that
marginalized peoples vulnerable peoples
special populations
get more criminal records than they
should because of the consuming
or selling of marijuana
that seems to be the umbrella
so
it confuses me a little bit now that
you're talking about
it's for the revenues for the populace
who want lower property taxes or
whatever
i feel a lot more comfortable
with discussing the
sale of
cannabis by the state
if it's to solve a problem
of us
leaving people with the wrong kind of
record
as they go out into the world looking
for work or education or to become a
lawyer
you know where they look to see whether
you have a felony charge on your
background
so i i see it i guess a little in
conflict
to start
allocating the revenues to so many
different areas
when the real
my belief is that i believe criminal
justice that that is why the bill is
here so i see those two things slight
not exactly conflict
but
not fitting together well
i i i understand your point again i i
look at it as the citizens are are
taking the risk for like a bit of phrase
right we don't still know what this is
going to look like
um and
i
blackberry phrase i don't want this to
go someplace it if we're going to do it
let's let's give tax relief right if
we're going to create new revenue a new
revenue stream for the state let's give
tax relief rather than just spend it on
some other program right
that's my general opinion we we we we
should be if we're doing this for the 78
of the citizens and let's give the
citizens back some money uh uh um
yeah i i don't know how to say i know we
disagree we're just going to disagree i
just i don't know i didn't want it to be
just it gets thrown into the general
fund and then somebody's pet project
gets picked up and says we've got 30
million extra revenue here what we're
going to spend it on and it doesn't go
to anything we want it doesn't go to any
cessation programs it just ends up over
in the general pool and and the money
gets spent on some ad program program
for the department of transportation to
you know
for for the
highways highway safety something right
and so and then it didn't help anybody
right it's just more money more spending
in the state so i was trying to make
sure that if we're going to do something
for our citizens we're going to they're
going to see a direct benefit right from
day one out of this program that every
citizen in the state of new hampshire
can do it i'll be honest with you if i i
represented abbess and i had this
conversation i'd had a policy issue in
here that says that everything that's
made legal by this process results in
automatic annulment of all prior
convictions
right that's a reasonable thing to do if
we're going to make it legal now then
why someone who got convicted two years
ago still have it on their record they
should be able to get it off but that's
a major policy change so i can't add
that in here as much as i'd like to
okay
representative
thank you mr chairman
and just to touch on that
i understand when there was annulment
legislation in the past
involving the nominal convictions
related to cannabis that that was a
strong point of contention
the idea was to
address that in in future legislation
and not let this get held up on on that
policy provision i'm i agree with you
with i'm not talking about
i'm talking about this so the overall
purpose of the bill
is to make sure that in the future
our youth particularly will not be
handicapped by having criminal record
which they don't deserve
in
but even if you have a conviction even
if it's no longer a crime you still have
to petition to the court for the
annulment and the qualifications to get
that annulment we didn't include that in
this this legislation for that reason
that we didn't want to get held up on
that provision which we thought could be
better served on a standalone that was
what we discussed in criminal justice
okay i want to find out where we stand
go ahead represent helene
the language on page 14
the appropriation
the
the sum of
4.6 million
is
for the fiscal year ending june 30th
2023 is appropriated
does that
mean as i think it means
that it goes back to the general fund if
they haven't spent all of it yet
and are they going to be able in
one year and maybe one month one year
probably
on
build
and open and get enough money from the
first three stores
to be able to pay it back and have money
to continue going away because this is
sorry okay grab representative hatch so
again i uh the money is allocated so for
next year they can begin to do their
stores um
the uh reality is that we'll be in the
middle of a budget cycle right after
that right and so we're gonna give them
money for basically the first six months
but start january we're in a budget
cycle to pass hb one and two all over
again and and what happens and so the
idea was to give them their their first
three stores off the ground out of this
year's in theory there is no
appropriation for next year because it
becomes a revolving fund at that point
so it's a matter of giving them the
money they need for the first six months
to open the first three stores
so
this money automatically it would
there's no lapsing language correct
non-lapsing language correct would it go
into
the revolving fund that would be it
would be assigned to the cannabis
control fund representative hatch who
knows
that
wait let me start with the question
again
yeah on
if
4.6 million is
appropriated for the fiscal year ending
june thirtieth twenty twenty three and
there is non-lapsing language in here
it's under the cannabis control fund
which with their net operating costs
fall out of so right in the first line
of the creation of the non of the uh
cannabis control fund says there is
established state treasury a non-lapsing
fund known to be the cannabis control
fund it is on page
look at page eight
uh number
well it's 1a
um but we do create and then
um
so
so it would not last so the 4.6 would go
into the cannabis control fund then it
would not lapse and they'd be able to
use it for the creation of their stores
okay
it's on the same basis
everybody understands
if you go to page 10 if you go to page 8
line 30 35 and 36
not later than june 30 2027 the
commission shall reimburse the general
fund from the cannabis control fund
for any initial or set up funds
appropriated to the commission for the
blah blah blah okay
we can pay if we decide to or if the
house decides to they can pay
they can pay this off all at one time or
it doesn't necessarily have to be paid
back in any schedule is that correct
that's correct we put a date in so that
in the first few years they can keep
more money to be able to open more
stores but then the later years they can
you know
basically a balloon payment to pay it
off right i just want to make sure we
correct they get they just get startup
funds and then they have to pay back the
startup funds
all right i want to know
where do we stand on
this amendment
relative to your changes
so uh based on the the amendment you
have in front of you i have one two
three four five changes i'm proposing to
that amendment
which
yep i'll review them real quick so based
so on from 11 52 the changes i have is
at representative
um
tucker's request i'm adding the word all
in front of it so it reads all cannabis
stores online on page 1 line 16 i'm
changing letter d to read all cannabis
stores shall be operated by the state of
new hampshire
so i'm adding that one
on under the health and safety rules
i'm changing that line to read
hold on let me find it this is the one
representative only had
what requested it's on page six
right near the top section
um
seven
and i'm just going to add it's going to
say health and safety rules including
regarding the packaging and preparing of
cannabis comma presence of contaminants
comma and the re restricting the use of
pesticides that may be dangerous to
cannabis consumers so it just requires
that they generate rules to deal with
the presence of cat of contaminants
and
thank you mr real real quick um uh
representative lang should that say
cannabis products
to be consistent with the changes for
and then on that same page line i'm not
sure what line it is it's the
requirements for testing
uh i've changed it to read requirements
for the testing requirements for testing
of all cannabis
products including for potency so
requires them to test all the products
what was that representative
yeah we i added the rules up and above
this
this is saying that testing
would include potency and contamination
i can do that it's fine that's not a
so that line will now read requirements
for testing on all cannabis products for
then if we go down to page 10 i believe
line round line 18. let me see if i can
what do you have in section six
no i'm leaving i'm leaving uh that's
i'll get to that one i'm sorry it's not
on that
so on page on page six i have the
provision for the atcs where i said
notwithstanding rsa126x and i'll turn
the treatment center registered pursuant
to
uh pursuant to rsa126x may file for an
application to obtain a separate
registration operate as a for-profit
cannabis cultivation and the rest of
it's all the same so i just added the in
the front i added notwithstanding 126x
well we i think we left it i think we we
said we're going to leave it that way
because we realize they can run
they can have a for-profit component
underneath their not-for-profit
organization
i okay with striking that separate
president tucker yes i wondered whether
we could ask
the person who really knows about atc's
to comment on this now that we have this
get to get his
first take on the wording
thank you i'll just be very brief we've
run this by our the previous draft by
our attorneys i haven't heard back from
them yet i'm expecting to get on the
phone with them later this afternoon
it's above my pay grade so i still don't
really understand whether this is
workable or not from our perspective it
might be
i'll get back to you as soon as i can
okay
thank you
and then lastly mr chair online
the authorization language i think it's
in 10.
let me find it
commission rule making commission to
sell
so um so under section on line 11 i
believe it is
um
we're going to change that line let me
so we're just going to change that line
basically make it clear that we're
allowing themself
cannabis products allowed by the statute
as well as therapeut therapeutic
cannabis products allowed by the people
with only with therapeutic cards under
rsa 126x
so again it allows
them to this is that differential it
says under
under the retail side you can only sell
everything but edibles but on the you
can have a case of edibles but they can
only be sold to people with a
and we're changing um the
the medicinal
and that's it that's all of them that's
all the changes we have for this last
amendment i'm going to send in
there was something
else that everybody i thought had agreed
with that you'd have to do a search and
replace where cannabis should be
cannabis products
correct
represent
avis
thank you mr chairman
i i'm kind of going back and forth in my
head i understand why
having it read cannabis products but
maybe it should say cannabis and
cannabis products because in the
definition section
is the definition of cannabis and then
there's a definition of cannabis
products i think including both
i don't think would be a problem
and i just i'm cautious by saying just
cannabis products are we then losing
then i would interpret that to exclude
the definition of cannabis so say
cannabis and cannabis products and
that's what i put i just change it based
on that comment
be careful be careful
cannabis
let me just read the division of
the
roman two on page two
implicitly says that
on food drink or other product
is
part of cannabis
so
this is a this is if we have an english
teacher in the room um
when i read this this is two sentences
the first one talks about cannabis
and then it says cannabis shall not
include in the entire second sentence
yeah so
my
the way i read this
was that under the definition of
cannabis
um it doesn't include these other things
it does include hemp doesn't include
fiber produced from the stocks oil or
cake made from the seeds of the plant it
doesn't include sterilized seeds of the
plant that are incapable of germination
it doesn't include the weight of any
other ingredient combined with cannabis
to prepare topical oral food a drink or
other products so it's weird because the
phrase they use is
or the weight of any other ingredient
yes and what it means brownies and
things like that right
would not be included in the definition
of cannabis which is okay because we're
not selling but it's it's saying that
the cannabis itself
is not part of this prohibition
right the way i read it is the first
sentence is really what cannabis is the
oh
by the way
representative so that's the whole
sentence
i mean that whole sentence this whole
subject
the whole section is a run-on sentence
i think that's why i was looking i was
looking for an english major i looked at
and i tried to figure out how to rewrite
it and i'm like
i'm trying to make it two
well sentences
is two sentences right because the first
half i'm looking for the period where's
the paper it's it's on line
10.
yeah oh i'm i'm oh
period i'm looking at line i'm down the
bottom here all right what's what
definition
there's too many ants in here
so remember that was rewritten because
we dealt with uh we dealt with the oral
so the new sentence in that on line 31
reads cannabis products means
concentrated cannabis products and
cannabis products that have been
comprised of cannabis and other
ingredients and are intended for
personal use such as but not limited to
creams ointments tinctures period for
the purposes of this paragraph cannabis
products shall not include cannabis
infused food or drink products included
including but not limited to cannabis
infused edibles such as candies gummies
brownies cookies
or cannabis infused alcoholic
non-alcoholic beverages alcoholic drinks
or beverages of any kind so that was
rewritten pat so you have an old copy
well yeah that second sentence is a
whole new sentence but i still think the
first three lines is a wrong sentence
but you could check with him yeah he's
probably an english major before he was
a lawyer is that it that's it that's uh
that's unless we have something else
no i'm still i want well i guess so hit
the scene
and i need 20 minutes
okay but susan has a one more thing she
wants to have another change
yes well the same one look at lines 10
to 13 and leave out the stuff in between
cannabis shall not include
the weight of any other ingredient
combined with cannabis to prepare
topical or oral administration's food
drink or other product they're talking
about the weight of the other product
i'm still trying to figure out the word
weight means in that entire sentence be
honest with you i wasn't sure you know
are they talking about how much the eggs
wave to make a brownie
you know i'm not dr uh murphy is here he
may be able to speak to
pharmacists who use compounding agents
for topicals is that something
the weight might be
i likewise do not understand what the
weight means as it applies to that
sentence so
i'm not a pharmacist but i also say that
um that that word is not familiar to me
in um any pharmacology that i've ever
seen
i think the intent of that was not to
criminalize or have any way hemp
products and those kind of things that
are could actually get caught up in a
cannabis definition and it was to
exclude those kind of products out from
the definition of cannabis for the
purpose of the statute
yes but it does not exclude
cannabis can't we just can we just solve
this by
who drink it or other products we don't
well can i take a crack at the weight
thing
let's say let's say it's a
chocolate bar that's infused with
cannabis
the they they they always talk in terms
of grams grams of what measure of weight
okay so maybe that's why it's there i'm
just guessing that's that's why it's
there that's why it's there
but
cannabis products become something very
different
if you are reading that
just if you are not reading that to say
robson avis
thank you mr chairman this was the
intent or goal whether it was achieved
or not that's another story but
and when you're dealing with any
controlled substance it's normally the
cutting agent is also included as the
gross amount so if you think of like
cocaine
and if it's cut with a any type of
substance you would count the weight of
both the cutting agent and the actual
cocaine and that amount is actually what
you're in possession of
i believe the goal is to not do that
with cannabis or cannabis products if
you have a chocolate bar that weighs
20 grams but it only has 5 grams of thc
in it the idea of how much you have is
supposed to be 5 grams
much easier when the product is labeled
so we don't want it to be confused
that because the total weight of the
chocolate bar is not what should be the
measuring stick for
quantity limits or possession limits
that's least the intent and if anyone
can help clarify that that would be
beneficial to the public and everyone
involved
i have a suggestion
why don't we leave it the way it is
and then let's come up with a definition
of white how
where it relates to this
and make sure that definition is
available for the senate
can you turn your mic on
how about taking a crack at using a
parenthesis around the word grams after
well
i still would let's just keep it the way
it is
my problem is the other side of this
you're taking that sentence to say that
cannabis
does not include food and drinks and
we've got cannabis instead of cannabis
products everywhere in here
and if and it doesn't
exclude food and drink cannabis products
romans 7 that's
line 31 does
represents
thank you mr chairman i think that once
it's made into a drink it's now a
manufactured product and therefore it
would be considered a cannabis product
under
on page two lines
31 to 33. when it's i think when it's
just in it's when you're defining
cannabis you're really just talking
about it in this raw form and how in the
materials you would eventually combined
to make a manufacturer product but until
it's combined
it's it's not a manufactured product yet
so i think once it's combined and i
think that's what the second sentence
that makes sense for
line seven
it does but then we've got a problem
that
most of the bill says cannabis
and
line 31 removes food and drinks from
what we're talking about
anita
thank you mr chairman um
would it help
if the final phrase
of the cannabis definition
in the cannabis shall not include
would it help if the phrase in lines 11
to 13
or the weight etc
got moved out of the definition of
cannabis and into the definition of
no
i'm suggest
i'm not sure myself you have to read it
several times but
isn't it the combination
with other
cutting agents or what have you
that makes weight relevant and isn't
that only applicable and relevant in the
so if mr chair i think
i'm trying to paraphrase what
representative abba said but i think the
whole point of the weight argument is
that there's the weight of the drug and
the weight of the
of the byproducts so they have the
products added to it and the only place
it actually comes into play is when
you're dealing with
quantity right so how much of how much
how much marijuana do i have and what's
qualified what qualifies as cannabis and
i think all this is looking to do is if
you take all of these contaminants out
how much
plant material do you have that you
smoke right or how much oil do you have
that you you put on your body or use
right so i i think we're i actually
think it's okay where it is again the
only time this argument is going to come
into play
is
in the dev is in the prosecution side
and what what is you know if you have
four ounces of product what is
considered actual product what is
considered actual byproduct so to speak
um or contaminants and so i i would
leave it the way it is and leave it for
the language and then we can look at on
the criminal justice side over in the
senate if we really think it's an issue
i honestly don't after those i want to
leave it the way it is
so that's the majority
the object of the sentence is the other
we're
we're take we're saying that
the
other ingredient is not part of cannabis
in
section 2. in section 7
we are saying that cannabis products
do not include
but cannabis is defined as
including all of cannabis
except for seeds fiber and and another
ingredient which was combined with
cannabis
it's not saying this kind of cannabis
doesn't count
rubs
may i please address this for uh
representative elmi are you are
if i'm understanding you correctly
then
you would want to remove to prepare
topical oral administrations food or
drink or any other product from that
section and then we don't have
the double up of where edibles are
uh mentioned
or not or taken away is that is as
you're saying it's interesting
alternative would be to change go
through the document have the drafter do
it and wherever it is necessary change
cannabis to cannabis products
so that the right definition would be
used
i can do i can give that to the drafter
and just have him to go through and do
that just say
just look at where the definition where
cannabis is being used and make the
appropriate determination whether it's
cannabis or cannabis product is
appropriate
um
that's not a big lift i have no problem
with that is that okay
that was our last item
that is the last item mr chair if we're
okay with this i will send it off to the
drafter if people don't mind sticking
around about 20 30 minutes we can come
back and vote on it
right here's what i'd like to have do
uh are we okay if you're okay with this
to send it
to
what's your question
i thank you mr chairman and i'm not
clear in that when we talked about that
section six
again
you presented it in one fashion that the
profits would be
you know to offset costs for the
patients
and then last uh period when we spoke
the atc is being
able to be a for-profit what is the
legislative intent of this section
of this
chase thank you so again i did offer it
in both directions and it would seem
like it was the will of the committee to
allow a for-profit model to be able to
move forward so it was design it was
and explain
well what representative lang first
presented
was the fact that
and and let's be clear this is optional
this is not mandating that the atc's
become cultivators and we're not here to
rescue any
specific uh
business what it is is
as as i've heard in testimony their
mission
is to serve their patients and what
representative lang had explained was
if in fact they chose to take on
cultivation
delivery
at l
that those dollars that were generated
from that
were going to offset cost which seems to
be a concern
cost for their patients
so i guess somewhere i lost something in
the translation from where we went from
that point of the testimony to
unless i'm mistaken but no no i was
sitting in the same room here so again i
i offered it two ways you know we talked
about one taking away the separate
entity language and the separate
physical location language and allowing
them to basically operate under that
would say that they could operate under
their not-for-profit license and any
proceeds they received from sales to the
state would have to go back to roll back
into
the organization for the benefit of the
patients however we also heard then we
heard testimony about the access of
funds and the access of capital and
therefore it seemed like i thought we
had we had come to a consensus that we
wanted to leave that
language to give them the op the option
of opening as a separate entity for a
for-profit to be able to access those
funds if that's what they needed to do
that was my interpretation of what the
committee wanted to do was the second
one which was leave it so they had if
they wanted to open as a for-profit uh
sub-entity underneath the not-for-profit
they could do that to access capital if
i misunderstood and i wrote the
so this is this was on
i find again i think we're on page seven
six or seven can you read it
yep
so if you're up on if you're up on page
um
seven and we're looking at the the
number six there it says it starts off
with an an alternative treatment center
that's what the line starts on the
current bill
on amendment
it will say notwithstanding rsa 126-x
and i'll turn to the treatment center
register operate
pursuant to rsa 126x may follow an
application to obtain a separate
registration to operate as a for-profit
cannabis cultivation cannabis product
manufacturing or cannabis transporter
and the rest is all the same
so we just added the the not
withstanding rsa 126x and then for
profit to give them the option if they
wanted to
how's that
no you can't see me
let me yeah
that's fine i just wanted to find as to
where we were going with this
okay okay representative
i i still feel the last uh
seven words need to be removed because
one of their
points was that it would take a lot to
do another physical location
so i believe that should come out
my apologies i did strike that from the
amendment after our conversation i just
forgot that when we were talking about i
struck there still leaves it as a
good
anything else
then
are we all in agreement with this
amendment
then what we'll do is you can hit the
sandbox i already did
it take 20 minutes and that 20 minutes
and so if the amendment comes back the
expect it to come back
don't you think we ought to caucus after
we have it in print oh yeah
so it's after that we get the printed
version that we'll caulk us
if that's what you want all right mr
chair we'll come back in here for
maybe other people don't agree with me
come back here for 310 if i have the
amendment i'll hand out the amendment
then we can go right into caucus
and discuss and then come
you back
you can caucus twice you can caucus well
the amendment's being done
and then we'll get the amendment
look at it you want another caucus we'll
uh
we're back into a work session on house
bill
1598 fn
we have the new amendment which is
2022-1172h
representative lang has bought it and it
should
contain the seven changes that he talked
about so representative lane you want to
get it
sorry mr chair um again the amendment it
does contain i scan through it it does
have the changes we talked about uh that
are in there and mr chair i'd move we
adopt
uh my apologies we're not an exec
session
to that point uh i'll happily answer any
questions there were again the changes
we made we added the word all at the top
um
we
changed
the section dealing with health and
safety rules to add the
section about contaminants
we added the section about requirements
for testing to say that testing will be
of all kind of cannabis products and for
potency and contaminants
why don't we just show where the changes
are sure all right uh so
page one i got it because the numbers
are different now so page one line uh
sixteen
so that was at representative tucker's
uh that was page six well let me find it
i don't know if it's the same page
number
right that was right that was the
definition i read to everybody it's
um
the next one was i believe
under
you're much faster than i am yes page
six line nine
under section seven health and safety
rules it now includes the words uh
and then on that same page line 19.
i change that line to say requirements
for all testing
requirements for the testing of all
cannabis products for potency and
contaminants
page 7 line 10 that's a not withstanding
language we added and we took out away
one more section i sent him a note on
to deal with uh the sale of cannabis
i'm trying to find the one where it says
commissioners for selling
that line there i had a look at it to
make sure we didn't have a problem with
cannabis versus cannabis products
if anybody sees a section that says it
talks about the sale
i'll compare it to the old language to
see
yeah so they changed it and added and
cannabis products in there to make sure
that
so line if you look at line 10
i'm sorry line um it's line 18
it now says it'll do the commission to
buy and have in his possession cannabis
and cannabis products as defined by
and it refers back to the chapter to
so it also talks about
um so again if you
read this section
it says it shall be the duty of the
commission to buy and have in its
possession cannabis and cannabis prox is
defined in
318 f1 for the sale and the manner
described in 318f and to sell cannabis
therapeutic
purposes
for the authorizat as authorized under
126x so that gives them the
the ability to sell cannabis and
cannabis products under under this
definition as well as for the purposes
of medical that met the therapeutic
cannabis as well
yes
so i seem to have lost track of where it
says the cannabis has to be raised in
i'm sorry your question is where does it
say that yeah i gotta go find that up
not sure do you remember is it under
representative abbas
thank you mr
chairman so the way it came at least the
way it
initially passed the house
it didn't specifically say
that
the cannabis would have to be grown in
new hampshire
but any other state that i'm aware of
that allows for cultivation
those states are prohibited from selling
it out of state so for example maine
a main cultivator it's not that new
hampshire's law is the problem a main
cultivator maine's law will not let them
sell it out of state
so the way the bill was drafted and i
tried to do this as best as i could with
every provision that we came across was
to
draft it in a way that if the federal
prohibition was not there
that we would not have to go through
this whole process and basically rewrite
the whole
legislation so i don't believe anywhere
in the bill it specifically says it has
to be grown in new hampshire but weren't
you the person who testified that
we had a brand as an agricultural state
and that
this was an important aspect of this
bill well i think for when i meant
branding purposes like an atc for
example they could
sell their brand to the state and i
would i would promote that type of
policy
any cultivator they can have market
their brand
but if the federal prohibition were to
be
abolished
i'm not sure that a law restricting the
purchase of cannabis in the state of new
hampshire would hold up under the
commerce clause i'm i'm just
not going either way with that i think
that's it's questionable whether it
would
actually survive the scrutiny
so we kind of wrote it both ways that
it's it's going to be
it's forward thinking
but any other product you can't for
example i mean
wood lumber you can't say you only can
build houses using lumber from trees you
know
grown in new hampshire
that wouldn't again that wouldn't that
wouldn't work
so if i just declared daryl what you
said was there's no specific
uh prohibition from out of state however
we'd be bound by other rules and laws
that would prohibit us from growing out
of state or selling out of state based
on federal law but if that federal law
goes away then we could so because of
that where
by its very nature we have to grow
within the state
yes and the same would go for selling if
a cultivator in new hampshire wanted to
sell to maine
maine's the problem it would be maine's
law would not permit
a retailer and they would i can imagine
either face a penalty or lose their
license
well
i think when it comes to any type of
cannabis we're ignoring federal law
medical
retail
you name it so
that's when this was drafted it was
almost within complete
i ignored federal law as much as
okay
representative romney yeah so brand
means i mean also means there's
different strains
and one grower may have the specialty
strain the bigger the company is they
have to hire botanists
to engineer their plants to produce more
thc or different whatever so
it's they have there are brands that are
unique to a grower
see it's
it was implied if not directly said that
this was going to be a boon to new
hampshire
agriculture maybe so maybe not but
there's nothing in the bill to prevent
uh local farmers for getting into
business and that's the way it should be
it's like it's wide open as to who can
get a license
so if it's a farmer who wants to do it
they can do it but they're going to
quickly find that if they grow it
outside for once for a short season it's
probably not the best thing
and plus they have all the contaminated
problems
all the pesticide problems outdoors it's
more than than they were all pests
little little bugs you know
that that ruin your your uh lettuce or
whatever else you grow outside that's
why people do it inside
thank you
so like
represent tucker i think again i think
the idea was new hampshire is an
agricultural state and this could be an
option for our farmers who are
struggling to be able to have a solution
and due to the federal current federal
law they can't do it to state transport
anyway so by opening this business up it
allows farmers to potentially get into
the other thank you mr chairman the
other conversation that we had around
branding had to do with the with the
liquor commission
wanting to brand separately from the
alcohol commission from from
representative
thank you
okay so i'm trying to get my
mind around the cannabis products
and
you've made the change
where
this this is just a small point but it
may be a drafting error for the purpose
of this paragraph cannabis products
shall not include
a bunch of things
the paragraph
this is a definition that
starts out in this chapter
which is the whole
chapter regulation of cannabis but for
some reason you've got this clause in
there
that limits the cannabis products to
this paragraph
we can come back to that
let's let's take that
uh definition of cannabis products
which shall not include
food or drink products
and then go over into the into the law
and
if you go to page six this is just an
example
uh in the middle
line 14
our labeling requirements for cannabis
products
mandating this requirements for
packaging and so forth well cannabis
what's excluded by that definition
so is there going to be no labeling on
the
those products that
the liquor commission is going to be
authorized evidence
shelves for the
if i mean
so again i i the therapeutic products
are going to be
are going to be controlled by the 126x
statute that's right the idea that
you're totally separated they'll still
yeah they'll still they'll still be
labeled pursuant to that
that's okay
okay
next
that i think that was everything mr
chair we had we everything else we've
already covered in all the other
discussion points
um we've we've gone over the
distribution didn't change
the um
the definition was what we said it was
in the last this morning representative
lang has gone over the changes
any further questions on the changes
and saying none
then
all in favor of amendment
now representative elmi do you
a very brief one
okay then
we will
take some time to have a very brief
caucus
representative
mr chair i move adoption of amendment
2022-1172
h on house bill 1598.
i'll second that nope
represented it's been
moved by representative lang
all right mr chair i don't need to speak
to amen i think we probably talked it to
death today
okay uh
does anybody want to say anything on the
uh thank you
um
yes i i seconded this amendment uh
because i believe it improves the bill
and i also want to commend
the very hard work of representative
blank to
work with all of us to
get to a better place and i think he's
gotten us to a better place
that doesn't mean that i support the
bill as a method but we'll come to that
and we'll talk about that but uh
you know big things have been changed
like taking the banks out
moving to
a non-numerical approach to cultivators
and uh and little things like adding the
word all and
things like that have been
uh
have been faithfully listened to for the
proposals and then recorded so
so that's the kind of legislating we
shall all should be engaged in and i
commend again
uh lang and the committee as a whole for
working through this process so thank
you
okay any further comments
say no further comments
um
i think probably we should take a roll
call
thank you mr chair roll call vote on uh
the motion of um to adopt the amendment
representative abrami yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative abbas
yes
representative amman
yes representative doucette yes
representative aaron yes
representative genigean yes
perhaps have nunes yes
clerk votes yes
representative spillsberry yes
representative tudor yes
representative almighty yes
representative ames
yes
perhaps in bolden
represent malloy
yes
represent schaumburg
representative schamberg votes yes
rap sam tucker yes
represent gamarlo yes
represent lawton's not here
sorry
represent murphy yes
mr chair yes
amendment 11728
has passed now we're on the
bill mr chair i move otp on how with
amendment number 1172h
for house bill 1598.
representative lang moves out to pass
now we have a second
i can second it mr mr chairman if you
want me to then seconded by
representative lang do you have any more
you want to say
absolutely not
any questions or comments
see my comment
representative romney so
i'm going to vote for this
otpa but i'm going to vote my conscience
mr chairman
thank you uh
my friends from the other side of the
aisle explained their
hesitation of passing a simpler
amended bill that i proposed three weeks
ago because what they felt was a lack of
lockdown details
on expenditure monies for a retention
fund
this bill as amended even though the
trying to resolve the many issues has me
hesitating
because of a gross
number of lockdown details from atc to
the distribution of funds and the post
effects
definitions
so i just want to express that i
probably will not be able to support for
passing this unless we are
supporting an interim study
thank you
thank you for your comments
uh anybody else wish to comment
saying none then i'm going to ask the
clerk to call the vote on
ought to pass amendment 1117h
on house bill 1298. thank you mr chair
of the motion is ought to pass on house
bill one five seven i'm sorry one five
nine eight as amended by amendment
number one one seven two
representative abrami yes
representative ankenberg yes
representative abbess
yes
representative amman yes
rep sam dusat yes
representative aaron
absolutely yes
representative genetic genetically sorry
john john yes thank you
representative nunes yes
clerk votes yes
representative spillsberry yes
representative tudor yes
almighty
no
representative ames no
representative bolden
no
represent malloy
rebel schomburg
no represent tucker no
representative gamarlo no
rebzo lawton's not here represent chase
no
represent murphy no
mr chair
yes
mr chair of the votes 12 to 10 in favor
of ought to pass as offended
the vote being 12 to 10 in favor about
the motion
passes
and we'll go on the regular calendar
there's one thing
[Music]
and representative ames will do the
minority report which is for interim
study
okay
just one final comment uh on
what it means
for
funds to the
raised
so could you just briefly
bring us up to date on that yes mr chair
just as a clarification mr chair we're
gonna have another report by
representative ames their
recommendations will be interim study
and this is going on the regular
calendar yes thank you
um so again we had the financial
discussion about this the the using the
numbers coming from the uh liquor
commission on a 250 million dollar gross
revenue this and that assumed all
products
there would be about 50 million dollars
in gross profit that would become to the
state however we know that about 40 of
that number was the edible language that
we took out of the bill that so it's not
in the bill um which means that our our
gross revenues for the state are around
30 million dollars
i think that's all we really know we
know that the one thing we also know is
that that's going to be a rolling number
that's assuming they're up to 100
percent we wouldn't expect to see that
number until the end of the third year
that numbers start becoming true first
year it's going to be about 10 million
dollars second year 20 million dollars
30 or 30 million dollars
thank you
anybody else have anything to say
not
we're out of the executive session
everybody can go home and we will not be
that's right
right
you